CLEAR NEED TO FOCUS ON CAREER
READINESS AND CAREER
EXPLORATION BOTH TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF STUDENTS BUT ALSO TO
MEET THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEMANDS. SCHOOLS MUST PREPARE
ALL STUDENTS FOR A WORLD BEYOND
HIGH SCHOOL WHETHER THEY CHOOSE
TO GO TO A TWO. TWO OR FOUR
YEAR COLLEGE OR TO A TRADE
SCHOOL OR IF THEY CHOOSE TO GO
DIRECTLY INTO THE WORKFORCE. CG
PROGRAMS MUST CONTINUE TO BE A
PRIORITY FOR EDUCATION SYSTEM
AND WE AS A STATE NEED TO
MAINTAIN AND BUILD ON THE
INVESTMENTS WE HAVE ALREADY
MADE IN THESE PROGRAMS IN OUR
SCHOOLS. AND OUR COMMUNITIES
ACROSS OUR STATE. AND AS A HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER I SAW MANY KIDS
FALL OFF THE PATH OF HIGH
SCHOOL SUCCESS BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T HAVE ANYTHING FOR THEM
IS THERE AT SCHOOL. EVERY TOLD
THEY'RE GONNA GO TO A FOR
UNIVERSITY AND THAT THAT WAS
THE MEASURE OF THE SIX SIGMA.
SUCCESS THAT HE DIDN'T DO THAT
WELL. WELL THEN WHAT YOU DIDN'T
DO WAS VALUABLE AND THAT IS-
UNFORTUNATE AND I THINK WE'RE
SEEKING TO REVERSE. THAT THAT
PARADIGM IF YOU WILL AND WE'VE
DONE SOME GOOD WORK OVER THE
LAST. FIVE SIX SEVEN YEARS WE
THERE'S MORE TO BE DONE. TWO
YEARS AGO- ONGOING FUNNY RISK
FOR K. TWELVE CTV WAS SPLIT
INTO TWO PROGRAMS. HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION ON EACH SIDE EACH
GRANT PROGRAM- ADMINISTER THIS
CD AND THEN THE OTHER HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION BY THE STRONG
WORK FORCE PROGRAM AND ESTHER.
THROUGH COMMUNITY COLLEGES HI
SHARED MUCH CONST. THAT WAS
CREE BECAUSE I ALWAYS CALL. IT
SHOULD BE A CD I. STILL
STRUGGLE WITH WHY THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SHOULD. ADMINISTER K.
TWELVE MONEY. BUT THAT'S A
CONVERSATION WE MAY HAVE AGAIN.
TODAY WE WILL HEAR FROM
REPRESENTATIVES FROM BOTH SIDES
OF. THOSE ORGANIZATIONS OF THE
GRANT MONEY. AS WELL AS FROM
LOCAL SCHOOL OFFICIALS ABOUT
HOW THE TWO INITIATIVES ARE
SERVING THE NEEDS. OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS IN
ACCESSING HIGH QUALITY. CTP
PROGRAMS- SO WITH THAT- I DON'T
SEE ANY MY COLLEAGUES IN AGAIN
THEY'RE GONNA BE COMING IN AND
OUT. I ONE THINK DEBBIE LOOK.
HARD I'M PUTTING THIS HEARING
TOGETHER AND THOSE WHO TRAVEL
FROM FAR AND NEAR. SOMETIMES TO
PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S HEARING-
I'M GOING TO INTRODUCE PANEL
ONE WOULD HAVE THOUGHT WHAT'S
THE THREE PANELS TODAY. RIGHT
THREE PANELS. AND WE'LL START
WITH PANEL ONE- PANEL ONE IS
GOING TO FOCUS ON- AN OVERVIEW-
KEY A TWELVE. PROGRAMS AND IF
THEY COME UP THERE IS A AND-
NEIL- RESIN COUGH. NO TO ADD
RESIDENT FOR LEGISLATIVE ANNA
OFFICE I CHANGING NAME. YOUR OR
YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE STILL MAD
AND THE- TO. LUPITA ALCALA
CHIEF DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT.
KILEY JACKSON IN CHI JACKSON
DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT. OF
EQUITY AND ACCESS BRANCH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT YOU GET
YOUR FROM C. H. ET AS SANDERS
CENTERS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
OFFICE MR OAKLEY'S OFFICE WITH
THAT COME FORWARD PLEASE ALL OF
YOU NOW AND OUR FIRST WILL BE-
NED I THANK YOU AND YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY. AT THE-
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M GOING TO BE-
PROVIDING JUST A HIGH LEVEL
OVERVIEW OF-THE HIGH SCHOOL C.
T. E. LANDSCAPE IN CALIFORNIA
I'LL BE READING OUT OF A HAND
OUT THAT WILL BE DISTRIBUTING
OUT A LITTLE BIT LATER ON. JUST
THE STARTING ON PAGE ONE JUST A
BRIEF REMINDER OF. HOW HIGH
SCHOOL CT IS ORGANIZED IN THE
STATE- IT'S DIVIDED INTO-
FIFTEEN INDUSTRY SECTORS AND-
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION HAS DEVELOPED
CURRICULUM STANDARDS FOR EACH
OF THOSE SECTORS- I WILL WALK
THROUGH ALL OF THE- SECTORS
RIGHT NOW BUT IT'S A- FAIRLY
BROAD RANGE- EVERYTHING FROM
FASHION AND INTERIOR DESIGN TO
YOU AGRICULTURE TO
MANUFACTURING AND HEALTH
SCIENCE IT. PAGE TWO GOES OVER
THE- C. T. E. OBJECTIVES- IF
YOU VISITED A CT EACH CLASSROOM
OR OR FACILITY IN IN YOUR
DISTRICT YOU KNOW THAT IT LOOKS
VERY DIFFERENT FROM A
TRADITIONAL K. TWELVE CLASSROOM
BUT THE OBJECTIVES ARE ARE
BROADLY SPEAKING VERY SIMILAR
TO- THE OBJECTIVES OF ANY OTHER
AT K. TWELVE PROGRAM- THERE TO
PROMOTE STUDENT ENGAGEMENT-
TEACHING ACADEMIC SUBJECTS IN A
IN A HANDS ON WAY- TEACHING
TECHNICAL SKILLS IN PARTICULAR
TECHNICAL SKILLS THAT COULD
LEAD TO- COLLEGE OR- FULL TIME
JOB- TEACHING SOFT SKILLS SUCH
AS- TEAM BUILDING OR OR
LEADERSHIP THAT AGAIN COULD BE
USEFUL IN EITHER A- POST
SECONDARY SETTING OR OR-FULL
TIME CAREER. AND HELPING THE
STATE NEEDED SO WORK FOR
SCHOOLS BY TRAINING- MORE IT.
YOU DIDN'T SEEM TO SKILLED-
CAREERS THAT THERE IS A HIGH
DEMAND FOR IN THE STATE. I'M
JUST GONNA WALK THROUGH A
LITTLE BIT OF THE- RECENT
HISTORY. OF CTP FUNDING IN THE
STATE SO- PRIOR TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN FOURTEEN- C. T.
E. WAS FUNDED PRIMARILY THROUGH
A MIXTURE OF DIFFERENT
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS THE
LARGEST OF WHICH- WAS R. O. C.
P. OR THE- REGIONAL
OCCUPATIONAL CENTER IS AND
PROGRAMS- AT ITS HEIGHT. THAT
WIND CASA STATE ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR. BUT THEN WITH
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THEY'LL
SEE IF THAT AND THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN A LOT OF THOSE
CATEGORICAL AS WERE FOLDED INTO
THE BASE GRANT- INCLUDING R. O.
C. P. AND IN RECOGNITION OF THE
FACT THAT C. D. E. PROGRAMS
OFTEN OCCUR- HIGHER COSTS THAN
OTHER TYPES OF- K. TWELVE
INSTRUCTION. THERE WAS A TWO
POINT 6% AUGMENTATION TO THE
BASE GRANT FOR STUDENTS IN
GRADES NINE THROUGH TWELVE.
ADDITIONALLY BECAUSE THERE WAS
SOME CONCERN THAT WITH THE-
GREATER FLEXIBILITY OF LCF HAVE
SOME DISTRICTS MIGHT SHUT DOWN
THEIR C. D. E. PROGRAMS. THERE
WAS A REQUIREMENT THAT-
DISTRICTS SPEND NO LESS ON ROC
PIECE FOR THE FIRST TWO YEARS
OF L. C. F. F. AND THEY HAD A
AND THE YEAR PRIOR TELL CASF IN
IN TWENTY TWELVE THIRTEEN. IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN SIXTEEN THE
STATE ESTABLISHED A NEW
CATEGORICAL PROGRAM THAT WAS TO
RUN FOR THREE YEARS. CALLED
THE- CAREER- TECHNICAL
EDUCATION INCENTIVE GRANT OR OR
SEATED. AND AT THAT ONE-
FUNDED- COMPETITIVE GRANTS FOR-
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ANOTHER ALLEY
ETS. TO FUND THEIR C. T. E.
PROGRAMS- FOR A PERIOD OF THREE
YEARS- BEGINNING IN A FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN WHEN FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION WAS ADVOCATES-
ALLOCATED FOR THE PROGRAM IN
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN THREE HUNDRED
MILLION WAS ALLOCATED. AND THEN
IN- SAYS- SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
TWO HUNDRED MILLION. AND AS AS
THE GRANT SCALED DOWN THERE WAS
ALSO A CHANGE IN HOW MUCH THE-
GRANT T. WAS SUPPOSED TO MATCH
THOSE FUNDS. SO INITIALLY IT
WAS A- ONE TO ONE MATCH- IN
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN- ELLIE IS
WERE ASKED TO- CONTRIBUTE ONE
DOLLAR AND FIFTY CENTS FOR
EVERY DOLLAR STATE FUNDS AND
THEN IN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN IT
WAS A TWO TO ONE MATCH. AND
THEN IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
SEATED WAS CONVERTED INTO AN
ONGOING PROGRAM WITH A HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN ON
GOING FUNDS. KEPT AT A TWO TO
ONE MATCH- AT THE SAME TIME THE
STATE ALSO CREATED THE- HIGH
SCHOOL STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAM ANOTHER ON GOING
PROGRAM- HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING. ALSO A TWO TO
ONE MATCH. THE DIFFERENCE IS
THAT- SEE TAKE WAS ADMINISTERED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
WHEREAS THE HIGH SCHOOL STRONG
WORK FORCE PROGRAM IS
ADMINISTERED BY THE- COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
ALSO WHERE AS A C. TAKE
PROVIDES COMPETITIVE GRANTS
DIRECTLY TO ELLIE ETS- ON THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SIDE. THERE
IS A GROUP OF- REGIONAL STRONG
WORK FIRST CAN SHORT CONSORTIA-
OVER ALL THE DIFFERENT REGIONS
OF THE STATE AND- THEY RECEIVE
FUNDS- ON A- BASED ON A
FORMULA. THAT TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT ATTENDANCE AND REGIONAL
WORKFORCE NEEDS- IT THEN- THOSE
CONSORTIA AWARD THE GRANTS ON A
COMPETITIVE BASIS TO ELLIE A IS.
JUST A TACO A LITTLE BRIEFLY
ABOUT C. T. ACCOUNTABILITY
UNDER LC FF. AGAIN SIMILAR TO
HOW THE OBJECTIVES OF C. T. E.
ARE BROADLY SIMILAR TO THOSE OF
OTHER K. TWELVE PROGRAMS
ACCOUNTABILITY ALSO LOOKS
BROADLY THE SAME- THE PRIMARY
INDICATOR THAT'S USED TO
EVALUATE C. T. E. IS THE
COLLEGE AND CAREER READINESS
INDICATOR WHICH IS- ALSO PART
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
DASHBOARD- AND SCHOOL DISTRICT-
CAPS- REGARDLESS OF WHAT THEIR
CTP PROGRAMS LOOK LIKE OR
WHETHER THEY HAVE CTP PROGRAMS.
AND THE FINAL PAGE WHEN YOU
RECEIVE THE HAND OUT. GOES INTO
A LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL ABOUT
WHAT THE- COLLEGE AND CAREER
READINESS INDICATOR LOOKS LIKE-
FOR NOW I'LL JUST SAY. THAT
ALTHOUGH THE STATE HAS MADE
SOME RECENT IMPROVEMENT WHEN IT
COMES TO- COLLEGE AND CAREER
READINESS THERE'S STILL SOME
WEIGHT GOOD TO GO. SO IN- AT
TWENTY NINETEEN THE GRADUATING
CLASS OF TWENTY NINETEEN. 44%
OF THOSE STUDENTS WERE DEEMED
PREPARED FOR COLLEGE WHICH WAS
A SLIGHT IMPROVEMENT OVER 40%
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. BUT 39% IN
TWENTY NINETEEN WERE STILL
CONSIDERED NOT PREPARED. FOR
THAT CONCLUDES MY PRESENTATION
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL MEMBERS AND
STAFF MY NAME'S KIND JACKSON
DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION FOR DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION I'M JOINED BY MY
COLLEAGUE CHIEF DEPUTY. LUPITA
ALCALA- FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND WE'RE HERE WITH-
OTHER STAFF FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT TONY
THURMOND. APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WITH YOU
THE SUPERINTENDENT SUPPORT- FOR
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA. YOU KNOW AND I'D
LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
FOR YOUR CONTINUED IN STRONG
SUPPORT. OF FOR THE INVESTMENTS
THROUGH C. T. AND THE VARIOUS-
FUNDING SOURCES AVAILABLE
THROUGH CTP. THAT SUPPORT K.
TWELVE AND PARTICULARLY
CONVERTING C. T. E. INVESTMENT
GRANTS INTO AN ONGOING PROGRAM.
THE DEPARTMENT ADMINISTERS A CD
AND SEND OF GRANT. PARTNERSHIP
ACADEMIES THE SPECIALIZED
SECONDARY PROGRAM AND THE
FEDERAL CARL CARL PERKINS FUNDS
ALL PROVIDING SUPPORT TO CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA. AND AGAIN IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT C. T. E.
IS A PRIORITY FOR THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT. CT IS A VITAL-
FOR PREPARING STUDENTS FOR THE
JOBS OF TOMORROW IN CAN BE A
CRITICAL TOOL. TO CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP AND AS YOU ARE
AWARE EDUCATION RESOURCE
RESEARCH SHOWS HOW TECHNICAL
SKILLS BUILDING AND WORK
EXPERIENCES IMPROVE ACADEMIC
UNDERSTANDING AND ACHIEVEMENT.
CG PROVIDESA PATHWAY TO POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION AND
CAREERS. AND IT IS A LEARNING
EXPERIENCE THAT BECOMES THE
PRACTICAL APPLICATION FOR THE
REAL WORLD C. T. E. AS A AS A
PERSPECTIVE C. G. E. SERVES
NEARLY ONE MILLION STUDENTS AND
NINE THROUGH TWELFTH GRADE
WHICH IS JUST OVER HALF OF ALL
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS. AT THAT
OUR ROLE IN CT MORE IMPORTANTLY
THIS PERCENTAGE HAS INCREASED
ROUGHLY FROM 40% IN TWO
THOUSAND AND 10250% TODAY. AND
CTP IS A STRATEGY IT'S A
STRATEGY TO IMPROVE EQUITY AND
ACCESS TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
BUSINESS AND INDUSTRY AND TO
PROVIDE THE RIGHT EXPERIMENTAL
LEARNING TO STUDENTS IN ORDER
TO PREPARE THEM FOR THE WORK
FORCE. CT IS CENTRAL TO STUDENT
LEARNING AND SUCCESS AND IS
MEASURED BY COLLEGE AND CAREER
READINESS. GOOD AFTERNOON LOU
BE TACKLE THIS ALKALINE HALF
THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT TONY
THURMOND- HONORABLE CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS I WANT TO TALK TO A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE C. T. E.
INNOVATION GRANT WE ADMINISTER
VERY PROUD TO ADMINISTER. IT'S
A COMPETITIVE GRANT THAT HAS
DECREASED OVER TIME AS OUR
COLLEAGUE HAS- ALREADY
MENTIONED FROM THE LA YOU KNOW
FROM FOUR HUNDRED MILLION AND
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION. IN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AND NINETEEN TWENTY
ELLIE ETS ARE REQUIRED TO
APPLY. AND THE NUMBER OF
APPLICANTS WHILE THE NUMBER OF
APPLICANTS HAD REMAINED STEADY.
HOWEVER THE FUNDING AMOUNT
REQUESTED BY THE ELOISE HAS
INCREASED FROM THREE HUNDRED
MILLION IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
TWO NINE HUNDRED MILLION IN
NINETEEN TWENTY SO THAT'S A
DEMAND OF AN INCREASE OF 3100%
FOR THE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE THIS GRANT
WAS ALSO REQUIRES THAT AT LEAST
PROVIDE A TWO TO ONE MATCH. AND
IN STATUTES ACTUALLY REQUIRES
THE DISTRIBUTION BY EIGHTY
EIGHT CATEGORIES SO THE SMALLS
INCLUDE ELEAZAR OF LESS OR
EQUAL TO A HUNDRED AND FORTY
STUDENTS. MEDIUMS IS A HUNDRED
AND FORTY ONE TO FIVE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY AND LARGES IS FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY AND BEYOND TO
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND. THE
THREE STANDARDS WERE SET TO
EVALUATE APPLICATIONS INCLUDE-
HIGH QUALITY C. T. PROGRAMS
FIRST AND FOREMOST- SELF
EVALUATION AND THEN THE
REVIEWER SCORES. EVALUATION OF
THE APPLICATION NARRATIVE
INCLUDING BUDGET NARRATIVE AND
THREE YEAR BUDGET PLAN NOW OF
COURSE THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
THIS GRANT WHAT IS ACTUALLY IN
THE ELLIE ETS LOCAL CONTROL-
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS-
STREAMLINING AND IT HERE AND
THERE. BUT IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
THE DETERMINATION WAS MADE TO
ALLOCATE THE FUNDS IN FIVE
DISTRIBUTION CATEGORIES RATHER
THAN THREE DISTRIBUTION
CATEGORIES WHICH WERE USED IN
ALL PRIOR YEARS. IF WE WOULD
HAVE USED THE PRIOR FORMULA
WITH THE THREE CATEGORIES THERE
WOULD HAVE BEEN SEVENTEEN
MILLION LEFTOVER. INSTEAD IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN IT WAS
DECIDED TO USE THE FIVE
CATEGORIES TO ENSURE THAT THE
SEVENTEEN MILLION WAS FULLY
UTILIZED. THIS ADJUSTMENT
RESULTED IN A VERY SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE OF FUNDS FOR DISTRICTS
WITHIN THE 500-518-8211 HUNDRED
EIGHTY EIGHT. AFTER CAREFUL
CONSIDERATION WE BELIEVE THE
THREE FUNDING CATEGORIES IN
STATUTE THE SMALL MEDIUM LARGE
USE IN ALL OTHER YEARS EXCEPT
THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. AND
THAT'S PROVIDED IN STATUTE
PROVIDES THE MOST EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION FOR THESE FUNDS AT
THIS TIME. FOR THE NINETEEN
TWENTY YEAR IN ACCORDANCE WITH
STATUTES CD HAS WORKED TO
ALLOCATE THE C. T. E.
INNOVATION GRANT IN THE MOST
EQUITABLE WAY. TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF ELEAZAR WHICH EXCEEDS
THE ACTUAL AVAILABLE FUNDS
REMEMBER WE HAVE A NINE HUNDRED
MILLION REQUESTS FOR THE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION. BUT THE
ALLOCATION EIGHTEEN WE TRULY
THOUGHT WE WERE DOING THE RIGHT
THING TO PROVIDE MORE RESOURCES
FOR ELLIE ACE WE TRULY WANT TO
SERVE MORE STUDENTS IN GREATER
WAYS TO BE A C. D. PROGRAMS AND
OFFERINGS. BY DOING SO WITH
GREAT INTENTIONS WE CREATED AN
ANOMALY. WHEN WE WERE TRYING TO
KEEP UP WITH THE DEMANDS OF OUR
ALLEY ACE MOVING FORWARD WE
WILL ENSURE THAT ELEAZAR FULLY
INFORMED ABOUT THE FUNDING
FORMULA METHODOLOGY FOR
NINETEEN TWENTY. AND BEYOND
THROUGH STAKEHOLDER ELLIE
ENGAGEMENT VIA EMAIL WEBINARS
ANOTHER COMMUNICATIONS. THE
DEPARTMENT TAKES THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF ADMINISTERING
THE CTP. INNOVATION GRANT VERY
SERIOUSLY WE WILL WORK TO
ENSURE CONSISTENCY AND
TRANSPARENCY. HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE CD
OFFERINGS TO OUR STUDENTS IS
OUR PRIORITY I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE UTILIZE ALL
RESOURCES TO MAXIMIZE THE
IMPACT WE CAN MAKE TO IMPROVE
THE POSTSECONDARY OPPORTUNITIES
FOR OUR STUDENTS. MY COLLEAGUES
AND I ARE HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
REGARDING THE C. TAKE OR ANY
OTHER ASPECT OF K. TWELVE CT AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR NEXT. OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON-
HONORABLE CHAIRED MEMBERS- MY
NAME IS SANDERS SANCHEZ AND I
AM THE ASSISTANT VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR A WORK FORCE AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT DIVISION
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CANCERS OFFICE- TODAY
WHEN I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WITH YOU
AN UPDATE OF OUR K. TWELVE
STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM. AND
I'M GOING TO DO. DO THE SLIDE
SHOW FOR YOU IT'S IMPORTANT TO-
QUICKLY REVIEW THE INTENT OF K.
TWELVE FROM WORK FIRST PROGRAM
FOR THOSE OF- FOLKS WHO MAY BE
NEW TO THIS WORK THE K. TWELVE
STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM IS A
JOINT EFFORT BETWEEN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF ED.
AND IT'S DESIGNED TO SUPPORT
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE K.
TWELVE SECTOR AND THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES INDUSTRY BUSINESS AND
BUSINESS AND ORGANIZATIONS TO
STRENGTHEN CT PROGRAMS AND
PATHWAYS AS WELL AS SUPPORT
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES IN
DEVELOPING AND IMPLEMENTING
HIGH QUALITY K. FOURTEEN CT
COURSE SEQUENCING PROGRAMS AND
PATHWAYS AND AS YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC
COMPETITIVE IS FUELED IN PART
BY THE STRENGTH OF ITS REGIONAL
ECONOMIES. AND IT SKILLED
WORKFORCE SUPPORTING K.
FOURTEEN PATHWAYS DEMONSTRATES
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO
BUILDING A SKILLED WORKFORCE TO
MEET THE STATE'S LABOR MARKET
NEEDS AND TO ENSURE UPWARD
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC MOBILITY
FOR STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE.
THE GOVERNOR THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE CHANCE SERVICE OFFICE
AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF ED RECOGNIZE THAT
FOR THIS EFFORT TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IT MUST BE
RESPONSIVE TO THE UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITIES AND CHALLENGES OF
EACH REGION. AND MUST ENGAGE
THE EFFORTS OF K. TWELVE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND OTHER
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
STAKEHOLDERS. TO THIS END THE
K. TWELVE STRONG WORK FIRST
PROGRAM SUPPORT CTP PROGRAMS.
AND PATHWAYS THAT LEVERAGE CITY
AT E. EFFORTS INCLUDING THOSE
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
INCENTIVE GRANT. PERKINS FIVE
AND STRONG WORK FIRST PROGRAM.
THAT FOSTER COLLABORATIVE
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN K. TWELVE
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT A
LINE TO REGIONAL PRIORITIES AND
OPPORTUNITIES AND OFFER
PATHWAYS WITH HIGH QUALITY CT
CURRICULUM AND INSTRUCTION. THE
K. TWELVE STRONG WORK FIRST
PROGRAM COMPLEMENTS THE WORK OF
THE SEATED THAT'S EXPANDING THE
IDENTIFICATION AND SUPPORT OF
PROGRAMS THAT EMBRACE THESE
ELEMENTS WHICH ARE THE
FOUNDATION OF SUCCESSFUL CT
PROGRAMS. AN ESSENTIAL
COMPONENT OF THE K. TWELVE
STRONG WORK FIRST PROGRAM IS
ENGAGING IN CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT. SINCE THE LAST
ROUND OF FUNDING WE'VE
COLLECTED DATA AND FEEDBACK
THROUGHOUT THE LOW BLOOD GRANT
MAKING PROCESS BOTH FORMALLY
THROUGH INTERVIEWS AND SURVEYS
AND INFORMALLY THROUGH
DISCUSSIONS. AS A RESULT WE
MADE SEVERAL CHANGES FOR YEAR
TWO FUNDS AS YOU CAN SEE FROM
THE TIMELINE THE KATE TWELVE
STRONG WORK FIRST PROGRAM YOUR
TO PROCESS IS WELL UNDER WAY.
APPLICATIONS HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTED AND ARE CURRENTLY
BEING REVIEWED AND AWARDS WILL
BE ANNOUNCED IN LATE FEBRUARY.
SO I TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT- THE REVIEW AN AWARD
PROCESS. THE PROCESS RELIES ON
THE INPUT AND EXPERTISE OF
MULTIPLE STAKEHOLDERS FROM
TEACHERS TO BUSINESS LEADERS
WITH. EACH WITH A DEEP
UNDERSTANDING OF THE NEEDS AS
WELL AS THE OPPORTUNITIES OF
THEIR PARTICULAR REGION. K.
TWELVE STRONG WORK FORCE
APPLICATIONS ARE RED AND SCORED
BY SELECTION COMMITTEE TEAMS
COMPRISED OF INDIVIDUALS WITH
EXPERTISE. IN K. TWELVE CT OR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT INCLUDING
TEACHERS ADMINISTRATORS CHARTER
SCHOOL REPRESENTATIVES. CAREER
GUIDANCE COUNSELORS INDUSTRY
REPRESENTATIVES IN THE REGION'S
PRIORITY AREAS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FACULTY MEMBERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS. SELECTION
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATE
IN A RIGOROUS ANDCOLLABORATIVE
TRAINING PROCESS USING STANDARD
MATERIALS THROUGHOUT THE
REGIONS TO ENSURE EQUITABLE AND
CONSISTENT SCORING. AND A LINE
TO THE INTENT OF THE K. TWELVE
STRONG WORK FIRST PROGRAM. THIS
YEAR THERE ARE EIGHT REGIONAL
SELECTION COMMITTEE TEAMS.
BETWEEN TWELVE AND TWENTY FOUR
MEMBERS PER REGION FOR TOTAL
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
SELECT COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ACROSS THE STATE. HERE ON THIS
SIDE YOU'LL SEE A SIDE BY SIDE
COMPARISON OF YOUR ONE INTO.
SINCE ELECTION COMMITTEES ARE
STILL IN THE SCORING PROCESS
SOME OF THE DATA IS FOR
PRELIMINARY AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO SHARING MORE COMPLETE DATA
WITH YOU ONCE A WORK. FOR YOU
YOU ARE MADE FOR YEAR TWO THREE
HUNDRED AND TWO APPLICATIONS
WERE SUBMITTED AND SIMILAR TO
LAST YEAR THE GRANT FUNDS
REQUESTED ALMOST TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION EXCEED THE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
ALLOCATION. ONCE AWARDED- WE
HAVE- ESTABLISHED ACCESS TO A
TIERED SYSTEM OF SUPPORT TO
ENSURE SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION. AND THESE
INCLUDE THE K. FOURTEEN
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS
AS WELL AS THE K. TWELVE
PATHWAY COORDINATORS. WHO WILL
ALSO SUPPORT THE WORK OF THE
SEA TAKES. SO TO GIVE YOU AN
UPDATE ON THE PATHWAY OF
COORDINATORS ALL START WITH
THOSE INDIVIDUALS N THE GROUND
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE K.
TWELVE STRONG WORK FORCE ORTIZ.
WE'VE DESIGNATED SEVENTY TWO
PATHWAY COORDINATES ONE PER
EACH OF THE SEVENTY TWO
CALIFORNIA COMMUTE COLLEGE
DISTRICTS THESE PROFESSIONALS
WILL BRING WITH THEM EXTENSIVE
EXPERIENCE ON EDUCATION CAREER
PATHWAYS AND OR CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION AS WELL AS
A RANGE OF FUNCTIONAL
EXPERTISE. THEIR ROLE IS TO
SUPPORT LINK A LINE PROGRAM
DEVELOPMENT EFFORTS FUNDED BY
SEE TAKE STRONG WORK FORCE AND
Sí
GIVEN THAT THEY HAVE WILL HAVE
A DEEP KNOWLEDGE- OF EXISTING
CITY PATHWAYS THE PROGRAMS.
ELEVEN EXISTING SEATED
COORDINATORS WILL TO OR
TRANSITION INTO THIS ROLE
REGIONS ARE CURRENTLY ENGAGED
IN A PROCESS OF IDENTIFYING
BETTING HIRING THE REMAINING
SIXTY ONE INDIVIDUALS WHO WILL
SERVE IN THIS ROLE. WE
ANTICIPATED THAT ALL SEVENTY
TWO PATHWAY CORNERS WILL BE IN
PLACE BY APRIL OF THIS YEAR.
SINCE THE K. TWELVE AND COMMIT
COLLEGE APPROACH CAREER
PATHWAYS DIFFERENTLY. OF AN
EXTENSIVE TRAINING SESSION FOR
ALL PATHWAY COORDINATORS IS
SCHEDULED FOR THIS JUNE. ON A
TWO AND A HALF DAY SESSION WILL
FOCUS ON NORMING KNOWLEDGE-
NORMING AND KNOWLEDGE BUILDING
WHICH ARE KEY TO AN EFFECTIVE
AND ALIGNED. SUPPORT
INFRASTRUCTURE THE SECOND PART
OF OURS- SUPPORT IS THE K.
FOURTEEN- TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDER. THERE ARE EIGHT-
PROFESSIONALS IN THIS ROLE ONE
FOR EACH REGION TO PROVIDE
REGIONAL LEADERSHIP IN THE
DEVELOPMENT ADMINISTRATION. AND
ORGANIZATION OF PATHWAY
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPROVEMENT
EFFORTS. THE IDENTIFICATION
VETTING AND HIRING OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS IS ALSO CURRENTLY
UNDER WAY AND WE ANTICIPATE
HAVING ALL EIGHT. TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS IN PLACE.
BY LATE MARCH EARLY APRIL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS
WILL ALSO BE PARTICIPATING IN
THAT JUNE ONBOARDING TRAINING
THAT WE HAVE SCHEDULED. FINALLY
WE ARE CONTINUING OUR EFFORTS
TO WORK COLLABORATIVELY WITH CD
E. WE HAVE REGULAR JOINT
PLANNING MEETINGS WHERE WE
DISCUSS ALL ASPECTS OF K.
TWELVE STRONG WORK FORCE AND
RELATED PROJECTS. EARLIER THIS
MONTH WE MET TO DISCUSS THE
COORDINATION OF C. TAKE AND
KATE- TWELVE STRONG WORK FORCE
AWARDS CYCLES. AND ALSO ON
GOING TECHNICAL SYSTEM- SUPPORT
FOR BOTH OF THESE PROGRAMS
WE'RE ACTIVELY WORKING TOGETHER
TO MINIMIZE THE WORKLOAD IMPACT
TO THE FIELD WE ARE ALSO
WORKING THROUGH THE ALIGNMENT
OF OUR DATA DEFINITIONS EARLIER
THIS WEEK THE CHANCES OFFICE
AND CD MATT. AND WE WILL AGAIN
MEET IN THE NEXT MONTH TO
FINALIZE OUR DATA ELEMENT
DICTIONARY THAT WILL DEFINE THE
SCOPE OF WORK FOR BUILDING OUT
THE DATA LAUNCH BOARD FOR THIS
PROJECT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
I JUST COUPLE QUESTIONS HERE
FOR THE AUDIO WHAT WAS THE
TOTAL AMOUNT REQUESTED. A BY
BOTH SIDES THE PROGRAM DO YOU
KNOW. YES SO- IN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THE TOTAL MORE ABOUT
REQUESTED FOR SEATED WAS ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS. AND THEN- FOR K.
TWELVE STRONG WORK FORCE IT WAS
TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY EIGHT
MILLION. TWO HUNDRED FIFTY. SO
A LOT MORE THAN WE HAD
AVAILABLE FOR SURE. YES OKAY
AND- FOR THE CITY HOW DO YOU
ENSURE THAT APPLICATIONS IN THE
INCENTIVE GRANT WILL BE. ABLE
TO COUNT ON A SUSTAINABLE LEVEL
OF FUNDING- IN THE FUTURE. WELL
WE WERE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
IT HERE TO ME STATUTORY
INTERPRETATION OF- THE FUNDING
FORMULA ALLOCATIONS SO WE'RE
GOING TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
GONNA KEEP OUR- SCORING RUBRIC
TO IT HERE TO THE- SELF
EVALUATION LIKE WE TALKED ABOUT
WE TALKED ABOUT THE SCORES
REVIEW AND THEN WE TALKED ABOUT
THAT HERE IS TO EL CAP MAKE
SURE THAT THEY HAVE A- THREE
YEAR- BUDGET PLAN IN PLACE SO-
IF THERE IS A DESIRE BY THE
COMMITTEE OR- OTHERS TO REVISIT
THAT FORMULA WILL BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS ON. HOW
THEY COULD BE IMPROVED. SO
MAYBE MAYBE FROM THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES PERSPECTIVE WHAT YOU
SEE IS THE KEY DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN YOUR TWO PROGRAMS WE'VE
GOT A HIGHER FIFTY MILLION
ADMINISTERED BY A CD EVE GOT A
HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION
ADMINISTERED BY THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WHAT HE SEES THAT THE
KEY DIFFERENCES. IN MISSION. I
DON'T KNOW THAT THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE. SO MUCH AS A-
WILLINGNESS TO A LINE- SO WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT PATHWAYS WE NEED
TO ADDRESS THE CONTINUUM FROM.
THE K. TWELVE TO COLLEGE. TO
ANY OTHER HIGHER INSTITUTION OR
TO WORK. AND SO- IT'S REALLY-
FOR US AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE
ABLE TO IDENTIFY- AND WORK WITH
OUR QUE TOLL PARTNERS WHO HAVE
C. T. PROGRAMS AND ALLIED KNOWS
BETTER TO ME WORKFORCE DEMANDS
IN OUR REGION. SO I DON'T KNOW
THAT THERE'S- SO MUCH A
DIFFERENCE I THINK
FUNDAMENTALLY WE BELIEVE IN OUR
TECHNICAL EDUCATION. AS SOCIAL
ECONOMIC- MOBILITY- OPPORTUNITY
FOR STUDENTS- AND I THINK WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS A LINE
OUR EFFORTS TO BETTER SERVE
STUDENTS AND HELP THEM CONTINUE
ON THAT JOURNEY. THANK YOU. AT
LEAST ONE QUESTION THE POPS IN
MY HEAD WHEN. THE DAY ARE TO.
TWO I HAVE TWO DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS IT SEEMS TO ME TO BE A
DUPLICATION OF EFFORT BUT
THAT'S NOT I'M NOT GONNA ASK
YOU TO RESPOND TO THAT UNLESS
YOU TO DESIRE TO. BUT I JUST
DID WHY DO WE DO TWO THINGS.
MUNIFICENT WHAT GOAL. IT IS NOT
HE'S DOING THE SAME THING. I
THINK THAT- I THINK ME COLLEGE
LEVEL ARE KERR TECHNICAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS FOCUS ON.
JOB TRAINING THAT REQUIRES POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION AND SO IF
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A LINING A
PATHWAY. IF THEY STARTED THE K.
TWELVE SYSTEM THEY HAVE A PLACE
TO GO. AND THE FOR WORKING
TOGETHER IT'S A SEAMLESS
TRANSITION AS OPPOSED TO NOW
I'VE GOT TO FIGURE OUT WHO DOES
THIS TO- SO. IT'S NOT DOING THE
SAME THING. IT'S IMPROVING THE
OUTCOMES AND HOPEFULLY MOVING
STUDENTS THROUGH THEIR JOURNEY.
IN A MORE SEAMLESS WAY. CAN I
JUST. AS A PARENT TEACHER I
JUST TO GIVE SOMETIME CITY IS
AND ALWAYS. YOU KNOW. I THINK
WE'VE GOT A FORM GOVERNOR WHO.
WANT STUDENTS TO PICK PATH IN
SEVENTH GRADE. RIGHT AND- I'M
NOT THERE HEY AND I DON'T THINK
WE SHOULD BE THERE. I THINK CT
PROGRAM SHOULD NOT ONLY BE TO
EDUCATE STUDENTS. CERTAINLY
YEAH IT MAYBE. HELP THEM CHOOSE
A CREW BUT ALSO ENGAGES KIDS
KEEP SEVEN SCHOOL SO I THINK WE
NEED TO. KEEP THAT IN MIND TO
IN THE IN THE SKILLS YOU LEARN.
IN A C. T. PROGRAM BE THEY YOU
KNOW MIDDLE SCHOOL ON UP. YOU
CAN THEN USE LATER ON IN LIFE.
I MEAN I. DIDN'T DO WELL OF MY
FRACTIONS UNTIL SOMEONE HANDED
ME A PIECE OF WOOD AND SAID CUT
THAT A FIVE AND SEVEN EIGHTHS.
RIGHT THAT'S WHEN I REALLY
LEARNED THAT'S WHEN I AND I
COULD APPLY IT LATER ON IN
LIFE- I JUST THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING WE OUGHT TO BE
MINDFUL OF IT ON THE WE SHOULD
GET TOO CAUGHT I'M NOT SAYING
YOUR- WE SHOULD GET TOO CAUGHT
pPROGRAMS HAVE TO BE ALIGNED
WITH HIGH SCHOOLS BECAUSE OF
HIGH SCHOOL MY NOT EVEN OFFER.
A CERTAIN TYPE OF PROGRAM
CORRECT. HE WON'T COMMENT ON
THAT OR NOT. YES I THINK IT
GOES BOTH WAYS I THINK THERE
ARE- HIGH SCHOOL. AS THEY DON'T
OFFER. A ROBUST- PROGRAMS. AT
INCREASE TECHNICAL AGES AS WELL
AS THERE ARE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THAT DON'T AND I THINK THIS IS
OUR OPPORTUNITY. TO CREATE. A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING AND BETTER
ALIGNMENT FOR THAT. FOR THAT.
SPECIFIC REASON THAT. IN SOME
CASES THE STUDENTS ARE GOING TO
GET IT AT. AT THE HIGH SCHOOL
LEVEL THEY GET AT THE COMMUNITY%
COLLEGE LEVEL. OR THERE. WILL
HAVE IT AT THE HIGH SCHOOL AND
WE NEED TO IDENTIFY WHERE THEY
CONTINUE THEIR PATHWAY- AND IT
MAY NOT BE WITH THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE- BUT WE
HAVEN'T DONE A GOOD JOB. OF
ALIGNING. AND I THINK THAT'S
WHERE THIS. THIS IS HELPFUL TO
THAT EFFORT. ONE OF THE KEEP.
WE'VE SEEN IT'S REALLY NOT A
DIFFERENCE IS MAYBE I WOULD
MEET MEANT ADMINISTER BUT MOST.
IN NINETEEN NINETY WE HAD THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
REQUESTS FOR THE ONE FIFTY.
THIS YEAR IN NINETEEN TWENTY WE
HAVE NINE HUNDRED MILLION.
DOLLAR REQUEST. ARE PRO SAME
AMOUNT OF APPLICANTS. SO THEY
WANT TO GROW THEIR PROGRAMS
CORRECT EITHER KEY DIFFERENCES
IN TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE HEY
JUST HAVEN'T HAD. TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE LAST COUPLE YEARS
AND THEY WERE USED TO PRO
GETTING PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FROM A COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION SO I KNOW THAT.
YOU KNOW THAT'S ON THAT'S
HAPPENING IN IT WILL KERR BUT-
THAT IS ANOTHER KEY DIFFERENCE-
THAT HAS OCCURRED OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS I JUST HAVEN'T.
BENEFITTED FROM FROM THAT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN THAT
NEED BUT THERE'S A HUGE DESIRE
TO GROW CITY PROGRAMS. AND A
HUGE DESIRE THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT'S FOR C. T. TO
BE VIABLE VITAL GROW IT'S HUGE
FOR THE JOBS. YOU KNOW FOR
BUILDING OUR ECONOMY. I JUST
WANT YOU KNOW JUST THOUGHT THE
POPS IN MY HEAD AS YOU COMMON
THAT WE'VE HAD THIS DISCUSSION
BACK HERE BEFORE. SEE HE CAN BE
COLLEGE PREP BUT C. T. ISN'T
COLLEGE PREP RIGHT. IT MIGHT
MEANING THAT WE SHOULDN'T TAKE
COLLEGE PREP. PREPPER GRAMS
LABEL MCT. USE THAT MONEY AND
WHEN THEY'RE REALLY. YOU KNOW.
NOT A C. T. MISSION. OUR CLASS
SAM. AND I DON'T KNOW MINISTRY
GALLAGHER YOU WISH TO. HEAR I
THINK YOU HAVE SOME SPECIFIC
TERMS. IN YOUR DISTRICT THAT
WERE KIND OF THE TOUR SO I KIND
OF LET U. S. QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN A AGAIN EVERY YOU
ME TO JOIN THE CA THIS MORNING
FOR THIS. CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION OF CB IN SOMETHING
THAT IS CLOSE TO MY HEART I'M A
PRODUCT OF IT MYSELF- SO. YOU
KNOW TO THE DEPUTY. SEC
SUPERINTENDENT I KNOW YOU'VE
HEARD SO MY CONCERNS AND WE
WHEN WE WROTE A LETTER BUT
OBVIOUSLY AND HOW THIS HOW THIS
ALLOCATION IS BEING DONE AT
LEAST PROPOSE FOR THIS YEAR HAS
SOME REALLY SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS
ESPECIALLY ON WHAT I GUESS WHAT
WE LABEL SMALL LARGE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS NEO SO FOR EXAMPLE
IN. AND MANY OF THESE SCHOOLS
I'M NAING HAVE SOME VERY. LONG
LONG TERM EFFECTIVE C. T.
PROGRAMS- BUT LIKE COLUSA
UNIFIED. YOU KNOW THERE SEEN A
LOSS OF TWO NINETY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND 83%
DECREASE. UNDER THIS PROPOSED-
ALLOCATION AROUND FIVE-
CORNING. YEAH UNION HIGH SCHOOL
NINETY TWO THOUSAND THAT'S A
68% DECREASE WEAKLAND UNION
HIGH SCHOOL. TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
SIX THOUSAND SEVEN NINETY NINE
A 76% DECREASE LIVE OAK UNIFIED.
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED FORTY SIX.
DOLLARS A 75% DECREASE AN EMMY
AND THESE ARE NOT. LARGE
SCHOOLS- BUT THEY FALL INTO
THAT CATEGORY IN THE WAY THAT
THIS IS GAME ALLOCATED BUT THEY
DO AL EVERY ONE OF THOSE
DOLLARS MATTERS- AND ESPECIALLY
WHEN YOU HAVE THESE ARE PRETTY
YOU KNOW AND I THINK THE IDEA
IS SAY WE WANT TO. THIS TO
PROVE IN PROGRAMS THAT HAVE
SHOWN EFFECTIVENESS AND- AND
WE'VE SEEN THIS IN IN AND ALL
THESE ONES THAT I'VE NAMED. AND
I'M REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
FUNDING FORMULA. NOW BEEN
APPROVED AT THE NEXT BOARD
MEETING- SO MAYBE IF YOU COULD
SPEAK TO THAT A LITTLE BIT AND
THE OTHER THING THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE COULD WE PUT IN
FRONT OF THE BOARD. IN THE
DIFFERENT HOW THAT DIFFERENCE
JOIN THE TWO WAYS TO ALLOCATE
AND WHAT THAT DIFFERENCE IS
BECAUSE I THINK THE BOARD
SHOULD REALLY UNDERSTAND. WHAT
THIS COULD MEAN TO EFFECTIVE-
CT PROGRAMS IN THE STATE IF WE
GO FORWARD GOOD. THANK YOU FOR
ASKING A QUESTION. EDIBLE
IMPORTANT WHEN YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT NAY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN SOME OF THESE SMALLER
SCHOOL DISTRICTS- BETWEEN
500-518-8211 HUNDRED SAW OF 76%
A 100% ME THERE'S A HUGE
INCREASES WHICH WERE REALLY AN
ANOMALY BECAUSE IN PRIOR YEARS
BY USING THE VERY FORMULA THEY
WERE RECEIVING OBVIOUSLY LESS
THAT AMOUNT SO IN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN CLEARLY. I WAS HEARING
WHICH THEY GOT SAW A BOOST THEY
BENEFITTED FROM THAT- AND IN
NINETEEN TWENTY WE HAVEDECIDED
TO GO BACK TO AND HEARING THE
STATUTE WE AGREE WITH YOU- WE
WOULD LOVE TO WORK WITH YOU AND
LEGISLATURE ON. AMENDING OR AT
THE CURRENT FORMULA IN STATUTE
TO ENSURE THAT- THE ALLOCATION
OF THIS FORMULA IS MORE
EQUITABLE BY EIGHTY EIGHT IN
THE PROVIDING A BOOST PERHAPS
TO THE SMALLER AND SMALLER
MEDIUM SCHOOL DISTRICTS SO THAT
THEY HAVE A VIABLE VIABLE
PROGRAM WE ABSOLUTELY SERVE
AGREE WITH YOU THE MATCH IS
ALSO A PROBLEM FOR THE SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THE TWO TO ONE
MATCH- IT'S- RIGHT NOW IT'S FOR
ALL THREE- COHORTS OF. OF SIZES
THAT ARE REQUIRED FOR THE SAME
MATCH AND THAT COULD BE A
PROBLEM I'M SURE TO HEAR ABOUT
IT TODAY I'M SO WE'RE HAPPY
TALK TO YOU AND WE'RE ALL
PROVIDE THE STATE BOARD WITH
THE DIFFERENTIALS BETWEEN THE
PRIOR YEARS AND WHAT THAT
DIFFERENCE IT IS- SO THAT THEY
HAVE FULL INFORMATION. WE
ABSOLUTELY WELL WE'RE ACTUALLY
GOING TO BE TRANSPARENT OKAY
JUST ABOUT JUST SOME DATA RUNS
THAT SHOW THE DIFFERENT
METHODOLOGIES AND HOW THAT GETS
COMPLETED. AND. I GUESS MY
OTHER QUESTION IS RIGHT NOW HOW
DO WE- HOW TO SEE THE DEFINE
RURAL FOR THE PURPOSE FOR THE
PURPOSES OF POSITIVE-
CONSIDERATION IN THE STATUTE.
WELL GREENS STAND TO- IT'S
DEFINED FOR US- AND I'VE WE
BELIEVE BECAUSE THIS
ADMINISTRATION WASN'T HERE WHEN
THAT PLACE AND MAYBE SOME YOU
WERE BORN. WE BELIEVE THAT THE
CATEGORIES A HUNDRED FORTY ONE
HUNDRED FORTY BELOW AND FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY ONE AND ABOVE.
THOSE WERE PERHAPS IT WAS IT
WAS IT WAS. I THOUGHT THAT THIS
WAS A SCHOOL DISTRICT IS SCHOOL
SIZE AND NOT ABA SIZE WE'RE NOT
SURE- BECAUSE THEY'RE AWFULLY
SMALL- IT TOOK TO THEM SMALLMEDIUM AND LARGE BECAUSE EVEN A
SCHOOL- DISTRICTS AT ELEVEN
HUNDRED IS REALLY SMALL. AND SO
WE THINK THAT PERHAPS THE
INTENTION- WAS FORCED SIZE OF
SCHOOL AND NOT DISTRICTS SO
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT- WE
SHOULD DEFINITELY LOOK AT BUT
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE TO LOOK AT
WHEN AND ADMINISTERING THE
GRANT JUST WE LOOK AT THE
STATUE NOT THE STATUTE SAYS.
RIGHT SO THOSE ARE SOME THINGS
THAT MAYBE WE COULD BE LOOKING
AT IN TERMS OF CHANGING THE
STATUTE- AND ALLOCATION. HOW
HOW THE- HOW THE STATUTE
DIRECTS YOU TO ALLOCATE EXACTLY
AND WE HAVE RECOMMENDATIONS. ON
HOW TO MAKE IT MORE ACCESSIBLE.
OKAY AND THEN JUST FOLLOWING ON
THE CHAIRMAN'S. LANA QUESTION I
MEAN I THINK IT DOES BEG THE
QUESTION. OF YOU KNOW WHY DO WE
HAVE KIND OF THESE TWO
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AND I SEE
THAT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
PLAY A ROLE IN ALL THIS BUT-
YOU KNOW BUT I. C. C. T. IS
SORT OF. YOU KNOW AT LEAST
TRADITIONALLY AND I THINK WHAT
WE'VE SEEN IS REALLY BEEN IN
THAT CASE YOU TWELVE. SYSTEM OF
PROVIDING THESE DIFFERENT
COURSES THAT THAT DON'T
NECESSARILY SET YOU ON A PATH
IN SEVENTH GRADE I AGREE WITH
THE CHAIRMAN YOU KNOW BECAUSE-
YOU WILL KIDS WANT TO BE EX WE
WANT TO EXPOSE THEM TO
DIFFERENT THINGS. AND THERE MAY
BE SOMETHING THAT THEY REALLY
TAKE TO AND HELPS THEM LEARN
BETTER. AND SO. I MEAN JUST A
QUICK QUESTION ON THIS IS ANY
POTENTIALLY COULD AN ALLEY A
GET FUNDED OVER UNDER BOTH
PROGRAMS. IS THAT RIGHT- DATED
THE K. FOURTEEN- THE K. TWELVE
STRONG WORKFORCE AND GOES TO
THE LA. SO THEY GET SEE TAKE
FUNDS AND THEN THEY GET THE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION SO IT
IS THROUGH A COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROCESS SIMILAR TO THE WAY SEE
TAKE AND THEY HAVE TO APPLY
THROUGH BOTH TO BOTH YOUR
PROGRAM YEAH AND THE CVS AND
THE INTENT IS TO LEVERAGE.
THOSE FUNDS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE FOCUS REMAINS ON THE
STUDENT RIGHTS SO WE ARE
FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE CLEARLY DEFINED THOSE
PATHWAYS SO THAT THEY KNOW WHEN
THEY FINISH THEIR K. TWELVE
EXPERIENCE WHERE THEY GO NEXT.
RIGHT I JUST I MEAN IT IS FOR
ME LIKE LOOKING AT IT. AT A TEN
THOUSAND FOOT LEVEL I KIND OF
SAY WELL WHY WE HAVE TWO
DIFFERENT. YEAH GRANTS. I
REALLY LIKE I MEAN IT JUST
SEEMS TO MAKE MORE SENSE MAY
RUN THIS UNDER ONE PROGRAM- AND
SO THAT THEY CAN ACCESS THIS
AND CERTAINLY THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN MANY DIFFERENT WAYS
ARE ALSO CONTINUING THAT
EDUCATION THE TECHNICAL
EDUCATION ARE CRITICAL AS
PEOPLE ARE. YOU KNOW GRADUATING
EVEN PEOPLE WHO ARE LOOKING FOR
NEW TRAINING TO GO INTO
DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES. I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING MORE SPUR
TENSELY LOOKING INTO AND OF THE
CHAIRMAN HAS BEEN AN ADVOCATE
OF THAT SO ANYWAYS WILL. I
THINK THAT'S ALL I HAVE RIGHT
NOW. THANK YOU THANK YOU I'M
MISS- SAID IT'S JUST ONE MORE
QUESTION- WITH REGARD TO THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF APPLICATIONS
SUBMITTED TTT TO YOUR SIDE OF
THE PROGRAM. AT THE CDC TOOK
ONE UP. LAST YEAR AND YEARS
WENT DOWN TO. DO YOU DO YOU
KNOW WHY YES- WE EX THAT WE
ANTICIPATE IT'S BECAUSE WE CAP
TO THE AMOUNT. OF AN AWARD
COULD BE TWO TWO MILLION. AS
WELL AS WE- WE MADE IT SO THAT
THEY HAD TO PARTNER WITH A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SO- WE ARE.
IN A SENSE ENSURING THE
COLLABORATION IS HAPPENING SO
IN ORDER TO- APPLY YOU HAD TO
HAVE A COMMUNITY COLLEGE AS
YOUR PARTNER AND IN THE FIRST.
ROUND THEY DID NOT. SO IF WE'RE
GOING TO ENSURE THAT WE COMPLY
WITH THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATION WE REALLY NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT. THEY ARE
PARTNERING TOGETHER TO BUILD
THOSE DIFFERENT THOSE PATHWAYS
SO. WE BELIEVE THAT'S WHY- IT
LIMITED BECAUSE YOU HAD TO HAVE
NOT ONLY- YOU'RE A REGULAR
BUSINESS INDUSTRY PARTNERS BUT
YOU ALSO HAD A HAVE YOUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AS A PARTNER
IN YOUR PROPOSAL. AND THEN IN
ADDITION WE CAP THE AMOUNT OF
THE LARGER THE SIZE OF THE
AWARD. TO MAKE SURE IT WAS MORE
EQUITABLY DISTRIBUTED ACROSS
THE STATE. SO WHO IS THIS PUT
SO. GIVEN THAT YOU HAVE TO
PARTNER WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE WHO'S IN THE DRIVER
SEAT IN THAT EXERCISE. WELL MY
OTHER QUESTION WOULD BE DOES
THE HIGH SCHOOL HAVE TO MOLD TO
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OF THE MALL
AND I THINK IT GOES BOTH WAYS-
THE K. FOURTEEN TAPS OUR HOUSE
AT. THE COMMITTEE COLLEGES AND
THEY CATHOLIC COORDINATORS OUR
HOUSE WITH THE ELEAZAR. SO IT'S
ABOUT BUILDING COLLABORATION-
AND WE ARE WE'RE FOLLOWING THE
STATUTE AND WE ARE. ADHERING TO
EVERYTHING THAT'S REQUIRED-
MAKING SURE THAT- WE CAN COMPLY
BUT ALSO. FIFTEEN IT OUT ALONG
THE WAY THAT'S WHY WE MADE
CHANGES FROM YEAR ONE GRANT
CYCLE TO YOUR TOO. BECAUSE WE
LISTEN TO THE FIELD AND WE
HEARD THEIR CONCERNS AND WE
TRIED TO INCORPORATE THOSE IN
THAT SECOND ROUND WILL
CONTINUE. THAT PROCESS OF
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
LISTENING TAKING NO AND MAKING
IMPROVEMENTS ALONG THE WAY- SO
THAT WE CAN GIVE YOU MARKET
FOR. AND MORE OF ABOUT IT'S
GOING TO I THINK. I THINK THAT
JUST EVEN HERE AT THE STATE
LEVEL THE COLLABORATION BETWEEN
CD AND THE CHANCES OFFICES IT'S
MUCH. IT'S BETTER IT'S A
TIGHTER COMMUNICATION WHERE-
TALKING ON A REGULAR BASIS TO
TRY TO REALLY MAKE THE
SUCCESSFUL. I APPRECIATE THAT I
DO. RIGHT IT'S GREAT THAT IT'S
WORKING OF THE MOTHER SHIP I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE IT'S
WORKING ON THE GROUND RIGHTS
AND WE ARE LIVE. WE ARE TAKING
NOTES. GREAT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ALL- MOVED TO
OUR SECOND PANEL WHICH IS. OKAY
THE NAME OTHER. AREA DOCTOR
MARION DOYLE OF THE WILLIAM
HEART UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN DR SEAN TENENBAUM-
IN JULIE- CARRIER OF THE SAN
BENITO HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
I WAS IN SAN BENITO. IN THE
FALL. IT'S A GREAT CAMPUS HUGE
CAMPUS IMPRESSIVE PLACE THEY DO
A GOOD JOB ASSEMBLY A LOT OF
PASSION THERE AND A VERY
INTERESTING PLACE THEY DIDN'T
EXPECT TO FIND A PLACE LIKE
THAT THERE WAS GREAT AND SO
WELL DONE SO WELL RUN SO WITH
THAT- I THINK- DOCTOR DOYLE IS
GOING TO START FIRST. YOU MAY
RECEIVE ONE READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND- OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
CONVENING THIS HEARING ON THE
CURRENT STATUS OF K. TWELVE
CREW TECHNICAL EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA I AM DOCTOR MARIANNA
SIDE DOOR OIL I'M DIRECTOR OF
CAREER TECHNICAL AND ADULT
EDUCATION FOR THE WAY IN THIS
HEART UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SANTA CLARITA AND
PRESIDENT OF ACCESS CTV'S
COUNSEL REPRESENTING K. TWELVE
CREW TECHNICAL ADMINISTRATORS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. MY SCHOOL
DISTRICT SERVES MORE THAN
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND STUDENTS
IN GRADES SEVEN THROUGH TWELVE
WE HAVE BEEN CONSISTENT
RECIPIENTS OF THE C. T.
INCENTIVE GRANT FUNDS. GRANT
RECIPIENTS OF THE FIRST ROUND
OF STRONG WORK FORCE FUNDING
AND WE ARE ALSO APPLICANTS FOR
THE SECOND ROUND. I WOULD LIKE
TO OPEN MY REMARKS WITH
GRATITUDE FOR THE CONTINUED
COMMITMENT FIRE LEGISLATORS. TO
THE WORK OF PREPARING ALL
STUDENTS FOR HIGH SKILL HIGH
WAGE AND HIGH DEMAND CAREERS AS
WELL AS THE POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION REQUIRED. TO ACHIEVE
THEIR GOALS AND DREAMS. WE KNOW
THAT CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
IS AN ECONOMIC DRIVER AS WE
DEVELOP THE WORK FORCE OF THE
FUTURE. BY STIMULATING DEEPER
LEARNING THROUGH AUTHENTIC
EXPERIENCES WITH EMPLOYERS AND
RIGOROUS CURRICULA IN THE
CLASSROOM. A FOUNDATIONAL
CONCEPT AND CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION HAS ALWAYS BEEN ITS
CONNECTION TO POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. FROM TECH PROP TO SB
SEVENTY TO SB SEVEN- TEN
SEVENTY THERE HAS BEEN A
LEGISLATIVE IMPERATIVE TO OUR
WORK WITH OUR PARTNERS IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM. DURING THE PAST DECADE
HAS BEEN THE BACKBONE OF THE
COMMON CORE STATE STANDARDS AND
OUR MANTRA IN CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION. HAS BEEN TO ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS ARE PREPARED FOR
BOTH COLLEGE AND CAREER. WE
KNOW THAT THE WAY WE ACCOMPLISH
THIS IS BY WORKING DIRECTLY
WITH EMPLOYERS AND WITH ALL OF
OUR POST SECONDARY PARTNERS
INCLUDING COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TRADE SCHOOLS AND UNIVERSITIES.
ON BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. I'D FIRST
LIKE TO SHARE THAT WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT ONGOING COLLABORATION
WITH OUR PARTNERS IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM. AND
WE APPRECIATE THAT LEGISLATORS
MAY ACTUALLY SEE STRONG WORK
FORCE FUNDING AS A POTENTIAL
CATALYST FOR THOSE EFFORTS.
HOWEVERTHE EFFORT HAS BEEN
MIRED WITH OBSTACLES THAT ARE
PRIMARILY RESULT OF TWO
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT SYSTEMS
THAT DO NOT ALIGN AT VERY
FUNDAMENTAL LEVELS. NUMBER ONE
COMBINING THE EXISTING STRONG
WORK FORCE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FULL FUNDING PROGRAM WITH K.
TWELVE FUNDING. HAS CAUSED
UNDUE TENSIONS AND UNCLEAR
DIRECTION. FURTHER COMPLICATING
THIS THE APPLICATION PROCESS
SEEMINGLY REQUIRE DIFFERENT AND
VERY SPECIFIC GOALS FOR EACH
ROUND OF THE APPLICATIONS. THE
MATTER IS IN IT IN ADDITION TO
THAT THE MATTER OF A PERSISTENT
MYSTERY- MISPERCEPTION. THAT
THESE FUNDS ARE ACTUALLY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FUNDS
CONTINUE. IN SOME REGIONS K.
TWELVE DISTRICTSNOTED THAT
THERE PATHWAYS CHOICES IN THE
APPLICATION WE'RE CHALLENGED
WHEN THEY DO NOT DIRECTLY
ALIGNED WITH PATHWAYS OFFERED
BY THEIR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PARTNERS RESTRICTING THEIR
ABILITY TO EFFECTIVELY
IMPLEMENT STRONG WORK FORCE
FUNDING. OTHER REGIONS HAVE
SCARED THAT THEIR COLLABORATIVE
EFFORTS IN THE FIRST ROUND OF
APPLICATIONS WERE NOT LOOKED
UPON FAVORABLY AND NOT FORCED
COMPETITIVENESS HAS TAKEN THE
PLACE OF COLLABORATION IN ROUND
TWO. THE MODIFICATIONS MADE TO
THE FUNDING LEVELS AND A
MANDATE TO INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF APPLICATIONS IN A REGION
MEN'S THAT SMALLER DISTRICTS
STRUGGLE TO COMPETE AS THEY
SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE RESOURCES TO
ADEQUATELY DO SO AGAINST THE
REGION'S LARGER. APPLICANTS
NUMBER TWO BOTH THE CT
INCENTIVE GRANT AND STRONG WORK
FORCE GRANT WERE DESIGNED TO
ENSURE THE SUSTAINABILITY OF C.
T. PROGRAMS HOWEVER. I HAVE
HEARD REPORTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THAT CITY PROGRAMS ARE IN
DANGER OF COLLAPSING DUE TO THE
UNCERTAINTY OF FUNDING. WHILE
ONGOING THE ANNUAL REQUIREMENT
TO ENGAGE IN A COMPETITIVE
GRANT APPLICATION PROCESS FOR
STRONG WORK FORCE FUNDING DOES
NOT PROVIDE ANY DISTRICTS CFO
WITH A SENSE OF SIN CERTAINTY
REGARDING THAT ON ON GOING
STATUS OF THE FUNDS. INDEED AS
THE FUN OF ALL FROM YEAR TO
YEAR FOR EACH APPLICANT CANNOT
EVEN BE ESTIMATED IN THIS
CURRENT MODEL IT IS IMPOSSIBLE
TO ACHIEVE SUSTAINABILITY FOR
ANY C. T. PROGRAM. RELYING ON
STRONG WORK FORCE. THIS
CONTRADICTS THE FIELD
UNDERSTANDING OF THESE FUNDS
AND IT APPEARS TO CONTRADICT
THE LEGISLATURE'S INTENTIONS
BEHIND THEM. IT IS OUR HOPE
THAT THIS PROCESS CAN BE
MODIFIED TO BETTER MEET THE
NEEDS OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
THEIR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PARTNERS. AND PROVIDE CLEARLY
SAYS FULL COMMITMENT. EVENTS
NUMBER THREE IN SPITE OF THE
APPLAUDED WILL EFFORTS TO ALIGN
APPLICATIONS BY THE C. D. E.
AND THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE THE
PAPER BURDEN IS SIMPLY TOO MUCH.
DISTRICTS ARE FACED WITH STATE
FUNDING APPLICATIONS FOR CITY
INCENTIVE GRANT STRONG WORK
FORCE GRANT AGRICULTURE
INCENTIVE GRANT GROUP
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP ACADEMY
GRANT IMPROPER PROP FIFTY ONE
GRANTS. ALL DURING OVERLAPPING
TIMELINES. THESE TIME LINES
MAKE IT DIFFICULT IF NOT
IMPOSSIBLE TO BE TRULY
REFLECTIVE AND THOUGHTFUL IN
THE DEVELOPMENT OF EACH
NARRATIVE. IN ADDITION TO THE
APPLICATION PROCESS EACH GRANT
MUST BE MANAGED IN ACCORDANCE
WITH POLICY AND THE RELATED
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES MUST BE
AGGREGATED FOR REPORTING. AS
ONE COLLEAGUES SHARE WITH ME
ARE WE ALL TO BECOME FULL TIME
BAND MANAGER AT THE EXPENSE OF
OUR FACULTY AND PROGRAMS. AND
NUMBER OR WITH THE- FORCE
PROGRAM ONLY ACKNOWLEDGING
PATHWAYS THAT CONTINUE TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WE ARE
CURRENTLY LIMITING STUDENT
CHOICE IN PURSUING ANY OTHER
POST SECONDARY OPTION INCLUDING
TRADE SCHOOLS. UNIVERSITIES
MILITARY OR DIRECTLY ENTERING
THE WORK FORCE. OUR IMPERATIVE
IS COLLEGE AND CAREER FOR ALL
STUDENTS YET THERE IS A DANGER
OF TRACKING STUDENTS WHEN WE
NARROW THE PATHWAYS TO ONLY ONE
POSSIBLE POST SECONDARY OPTION.
WHILE IT MAKES SENSE TO
ALLOCATE A PORTION OF THESE
FUNDS TO SUSTAIN ONGOING
COLLABORATION WITH OUR POST
SECONDARY PARTNERS THIS SHOULD
NOT BE AT THE EXPENSE OF ANY K.
TWELVE C. T. PROGRAM. ON BEHALF
OF ACCESS AND MY OWN SCHOOL
DISTRICT WE ASK THAT THE
ASSEMBLY CONTINUE TO SUPPORT K.
TWELVE CREW TECHNICAL EDUCATION
STUDENT CHOICE. AND STREAMLINED
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING AS WE WORK
TOGETHER TO SERVE EACH AND
EVERY STUDENT IN OUR DISTRICTS
AND GREAT THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR HIGHLIGHTING. SOME OF
THE LOGISTICS ASSOCIATED WITH%
THIS GRANT AND HOW THEY'RE
COMPLICATED TO GET IT. AND IT
APPEARS THE RATHER COMPLICATED.
WHEN YOU DO GET IT SO THANK YOU
DR. GOOD AFTERNOON AUDIBLE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE IT'S- AN
HONOR TO SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY
IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU AS WELL
AGAIN- AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE OUR OUR LOVELY CAMPUS
WITH YOU IN OUR PROGRAMS- MY
NAME IS DOCTOR SEAN TENENBAUM
I'VE WORKED IN PUBLIC SCHOOL
EDUCATION FOR THE PAST TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS NOW SERVICES
SUPERINTENDENT OF SAMUEL HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT. ALONG WITH MY
COLLEAGUE I'M ALSO AN AXE A
BOARD MEMBER. FOUR HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE YEARS SAMIR HIGH
SCHOOLS PROBABLY PROVIDED
STUDENTS WITH ACCESS TO A BROAD
RANGE OF EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES. WHICH IS
INCLUDED A CONSISTENT
COMMITMENT TO CTP FOR OVER FIVE
DECADES. AND IN THOSE FIVE
DECADES WE HAVE NEVER WAVERED
IN OUR COMMITMENT. WITH TWELVE
CT PATHWAYS SPENDING NINE
INDUSTRY SECTORS SEMI HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT OFFERS ONE OF
THE MOST ROBUST C. T. PROGRAMS
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA ALL ON
ONE CAMPUS. FURTHERMORE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN THE
SEVERAL HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT
BOARD OF TRUSTEES ADOPTED A
SEPARATE GRADUATION PATHWAY FOR
OUR CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS. TO FURTHER SOLIDIFY
OUR COMMITMENT TO SEE T.
EDUCATION. WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE TODAY
AND FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE OUR EXPERIENCE WITH THE
GRANT WRITING PROCESS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
O'DONNELL AND JUST IT WAS
MEMBERS OF THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS JULIE
CARRIER I AM THE CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PROGRAM
SPECIALIST AT SAN BENITO HIGH
SCHOOL. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY I HAVE BEEN A CT A
CLASSROOM INSTRUCTOR FOR TWENTY
EIGHT YEARS.AND DURING THE
LAST THIRTY YEARS OF IT
EDUCATION I'VE EXPERIENCED
FIRST HAND THE FLUCTUATION OF
CAREER TECH EDUCATION FUNDING.
I WANT TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE
SPECIALLY THIS COMMITTEE FOR
ENSURING THE RETURN OF C. T.
FUNDING AND PRIORITIZING C. T.
PROGRAMS. I'M HERE TO OFFER MY
EXPERTISE ON THE FUNDING
AVAILABLE FOR C. D. PROGRAMS.
AS DOCTOR TANNENBAUM STATED WE
HAVE OVER THIRTY THOUSAND THREE
THOUSAND STUDENTS AND
APPROXIMATELY NINE HUNDRED
ELEVEN I DUPLICATED STUDENTS
CURRENTLY ENROLLED IN OUR C. D.
PATHWAYS. THE CITY ID FUNDS
RELEASED AROUND ONE TWO AND
THREE. WERE OF GREAT SERVICE TO
DISTRICTS STRUGGLING TO KEEP
THEIR PROGRAMS VIABLE AND UP TO
DATE. DURING THE FIRST THREE
ROUNDS YOU SEE TAKE FUNDING SAN
BENITO HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT
BEGIN WORKING WITH MULTIPLE
LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PARTNERS HOWEVER WITH THE
DIVISION OF THE ORIGINAL FUNDS.
WHICH WERE SPLIT BETWEEN THE K.
TWELVE S. W. P. IN THE C. D. I.
G. OUR ABILITY TO ARTICULATE.
WITH ALL LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGES HAS DIMINISHED THE K.
TWELVE S. W. P. IS
INADVERTENTLY CREATED PRESSURE
AND LIMITED OPPORTUNITIES TO
ARTICULATE ON BEHALF OF OUR
STUDENTS. TO PROVIDE THE
COMMITTEE WITH AN EXAMPLE TWO
OF OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGES
OFFER WELDING. COLLEGE A OFFERS
WELL ONE WELDING COURSE COLLEGE
BE OFFERS ELEVEN WELDING
COURSES INCLUDING IT A. S. IN
WELDING TECHNOLOGY THE
CHALLENGE IS BEING ABLE TO
ARTICULATE WITH COLLEGE BE. WHO
OFFERS THE BEST OPPORTUNITIES
FOR OUR STUDENTS. WHEREAS I
BELIEVE WHEN A TRUE NATURAL
PATHWAY CURSE FOR STUDENTS THE
PATH TO A SUCCESSFUL CAREER NOT
BE LIMITED OR THIRD BY THE
RESTRICTED AS OF A- OR. OUR
PARTY IS U. K. THE LIST TO OUR
STUDENTS CAREER GOALS IT IS NOT
TO. THEIR CORE GOALS MEET THE
OF A COURSE. IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNICABLE DISTRICTS. THE K.
TWELVE APPLICATION WAS ANOTHER
CHALLENGE SPECIFICALLY THE
APPLICATION WAS REDUNDANT TIME
CONSUMING LACK CLARITY. AND IS
INDUSTRY SPEC TO SET THE SECTOR
SPECIFIC. THAT'S THE CHALLENGE
FOR SAN BENITO HIGH SCHOOL WAS
TO CREATE NINE SEPARATE QUALITY
GRANTS TO COVER EACH OF THE
INDUSTRY SECTORS IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE. EQUITY FOR A PROGRAMS.
LAST YEAR'S A EXAMPLE I
COMPLETED NINE ALMOST IDENTICAL
GRANT APPLICATIONS OF WHICH
ONLY ONE WAS FUNDED AND MOUNT
OF SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS. AS A
RESULT OF THIS PROCESS SIMPLY
TO HIGH SCHOOL ROAD ONLY ONE K.
TWELVE SWP GRANT THIS YEAR. IN
ADDITION TO WRITING GRANTS
CLYDE AND ACCEPTED A POSITION
ON THE K. TWELVE S. W. P.
SELECTION COMMITTEE. THE
COMMITTEE SCORES AND CHOOSE THE
RECIPIENTS FOR THE K. TWELVE US
TO BE P. GRANTS. COMMITTEE HELD
A ONE FIVE OUR INTRODUCTORY
MEETING TO COLLABORATE THE
SCORING OF THE GRANTS. THIS
GOING PROCESS WAS UNCLEAR
CONFLICTING AND CONFUSING. EVEN
MORE SO AFTER THE CALIBRATING
EXERCISE. THERE WERE NO
CONCLUSIONS ARE AGREEMENTS ON
WHAT THE SCORE SHOULD BE IN
FACT THEY WERE EXTREME
DIFFERENCES IN THE SCORING.
FROM ZERO TO TEN. THIS ALLOWED
TO PERSONAL INTERPRETATION AND
BIAS IN THIS GOING PROCESS. THE
SCORING RUBRIC IS NOT AN
INTUITIVE DOCUMENT AND THERE
WERE MULTIPLE DISCUSSIONS ON
HOW TO FIX IT REGARDLESS OF THE
FACT THAT THE GANTS WERE
ALREADY SUBMITTED. IN CONTRAST
TO SEAT DOUBLE CATION WAS ALL
WELL OR- ALIGNED WITH BURKE AND
ANY COME. ALL PAY. ALIGNED BUT-
TO BE YOU TO. AND ADJUSTED
NECESSARY IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE CD E.
HELP TO SEPARATE TWO DAY
TRAINING. SESSIONS TO CALIBRATE
THE RUBRICS AND GOING PROCESS
OF THE SEATING APPLICATION. THE
CASE ALL OF US TO BE P. GRANT
EVERY WEEK OR SO ON BALANCE
LAST YEAR. THEY ADOPTED MANY OF
THE TRAITS OF THE SEATED
REQUIREMENTS FOR THIS YEAR
THEY'RE EVEN SHARING FORMS. IF
THE K. TWELVE US TO BE P. IS
GOING TO UTILIZE THE SEE TWO
CRITERIA. THEN THERE SHOULD
ONLY BE ONE APPLICATION FOR ALL
OF THE MONEY SCORED BY
PROFESSIONALS FOLLOWING THE
REGIONAL NEEDS AND ALLOWING
EQUITY FOR ALL. INCLUSION IN MY
EXPERT OPINION THE K. TOLD US
TO BE P. AND C. TAKE MONEY
SHOULD RETURN TO ONE COM COME
BY ALLOCATION. REALIZE APPLIQUE.
SCORED BY PROPERLY AND- THANK
YOU. I HAVE THE YOU CAME HERE
TO SHARE YOUR OPINION WILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND WE
SHOULD THE OF A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE WITH THIS. SO WE
DON'T AND THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO
HEAR FROM YOU SO LET IT GO
TODAY TODAY'S YOUR DAY. I KNOW
THE CHANCELLOR OVER THERE THIS
CANCER WILL BE FINE HE'S A NICE
GUY DOESN'T I MEAN BONE IN HIS
BODY I'LL TAKE CARE WE'RE GONNA
BE OKAY. I'M ON THE WHOLE ONE.
SO THEY MAYBE FOR DOCTOR DOYLE.
YOU YOU YOU GET A LITTLE THIS
CON BETWEEN LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AN ASSOCIATIVE. K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS CAN CAN YOU
MAYBE GIVE AN EXAMPLE OR TO
SPEAK WITH HER. ABSOLUTELY SO
THERE'S ISSUE- OBVIOUSLY WHEN
COLLABORATION HAPPENS BUT
THERE'S ALSO ISSUES THAT ARE
MUCH MORE FUNDAMENTAL MEETING
HAVING TO DO WITH THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BETWEEN THE
CABLE SYSTEM AND THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM SO
PRIMARILY THINGS LIKE THE WAY
THAT WE AGGREGATE DATA THE WAY
THAT WE IDENTIFY AND OUR LABOR
MARKET THE WAY WE CAN IDENTIFY
INDUSTRY SECTORS SO AN EXAMPLE
THAT I SHARED IS THAT ONE OF
OUR INDUSTRY SECTORS SECTORS
THAT WE- ARE VERY PROUDLY
DEVELOPING IS EDUCATION BECAUSE
THERE HAPPENS TO BE THIS
TEACHER SHORTAGE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT WE HAVE TO
ME. AND EDUCATION IS NOT A C.
T. E. INDUSTRY SECTOR IN OR A
C. D. PATHWAY EXCUSE ME IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM THEREFORE IN WORKING
WITH OUR MANDATED REQUIRED
COLLABORATION WITH COMMUNITY
COLLEGE WE CANNOT APPLY FOR
SUPPORT FOR AN EDUCATION
PATHWAY THROUGH STRONG WORK
FORCE CONVERSELY IN OUR AREA
ENGINEERING IS ANOTHER ROBUST
HUMM PATHWAY THAT WE HAVE THAT
MULTIPLE SCHOOL SCHOOL SITES IN
MY DISTRICT. WE CANNOT APPLYING
BECAUSE THAT IS NOT A CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PATHWAYS ON
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM-
SO THAT OBVIOUSLY IN OF ITSELF
BECOMES A PROBLEM AND AGAIN
IT'S A FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE WHERE-
IT'S NOT SIMPLE TO JUST SAY
WELL SEAT COMMUNITY COLLEGES
FIXTURES SYSTEMS YOUR YOUR
CODING STRAIGHT OUR CODING IS A
FOUNDATIONAL FOR THINGS LIKE
AND IN. THE WAY IT PAID THE AND
SO FORTH SO THERE NO NO AND
JUST. THAT THE CASE CSUS. A AT
AGRA YOUR DATA ALONG THE- GLASS
CASE. AS WELL I'M SURE THANK
THEM FOR THE COPS THE SOCKS
CODES IN IT I IT IT JUST DOES
NOT WE DON'T SPEAK THE SAME
LANGUAGE SO IF. EVEN IN AND
WHERE FOR IN MY WE WORK REALLY
WELL WITH OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE WE ARE. VERY VERY
CLOSE- AND SO WE AS MUCH AS WE-
STRUGGLE WITH THOSE
INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES THE
COLLABORATION PIECE IS THERE.
BUT THE INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES
ARE A HUGE IMPEDIMENT- AS
REPRESENTATIVE FOR ACCESS TO
AND HAVING RECEIVED A LOT OF
FEEDBACK FROM THE FIELD. IT
BECOMES MUCH WORSE WHEN THERE
IS NOT THAT SPIRIT OF
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND THAT THE
K. TWELVE DISTRICTS AND- THERE
HAVE BEEN SOME REALLY- NEGATIVE
A- EXPERIENCES THAT. HAVE
OCCURRED AS A RESULT OF THAT AS
WELL AND I DID MENTION WHERE
THERE SOME OF THAT HAS TO DO
WITH A- MISUNDERSTANDING AROUND
THE FUNDING WHETHER OR NOT IT'S
IS IT K. TWELVE FUNDING IF IT'S
K. TWELVE FUNDING WISE
ADMINISTERED THROUGH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. IS THERE FOR
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES MUST BE
ABLE TO ACCESS FOR. IT'S QUITE
FOR I TO THE. SO MY- MAYBE FOR
ME CARRIER. OR OR GOOD DOCTOR
ARE YOU MAY THE CHIU WERE WITH
YOUR TO COLLEGE IN THAT. THE
REASON YOU CAN OUR WITH ONE
MAYBE AND COULD YOU ELABORATE
ON THAT I WOULD IMAGINE EVEN
YOU AREA THAT PROBLEM AND I
DON'T HAVE MY AREA PROBABLY
WITHIN TWENTY FIVE MINUTES MY
HOUSE. I CAN ACCESS PROBABLY
FIVE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS RIGHT GROW WITHIN
TWENTY FIVE MINUTES OF MY
HOUSE. LONG BEACH RIGHT BUT IN
YOUR AREA I IMAGINE SOME OF
THOSE COMMITTEE COLLEGES THAT
MIGHT HAVE A MORE COMPREHENSIVE
PROGRAM PROBABLY. A MUCH
FURTHER DISTANCE COULD YOU
ELABORATE ON. THE ANY THE
COMMUNICATION RELATIONSHIP
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND YOU
MIGHT WANT TO BE THIS ONE YOU
MIGHT NOT NECESSARILY WANT TO
BE AT THE ONE NEXT DOOR.
BECAUSE IT MIGHT NOT HAVE THE
COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM UC AS
NECESSARY. AB SO THE EXAMPLE I
GAVE WS OUR WELDING. WELDING
IS ON THEIR CATALOG IN OUR
LOCAL COMMUNICATIVE STRICT AND
A WEEK WE ALSO A PHENOMENAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH THEM AND BUT
ONE THING SEEMS TO BE A
STICKING POINT- THEY- THEY
UTILIZE A LOCAL HIGH SCHOOL
WHICH GOT SHUT DOWN BY OSHA.
AND SO WE COULDN'T WE DIDN'T
THEY DIDN'T AND THEN OFFERED IN
THE LAST YEAR- AND SO WHAT WE
WANTED TO DO WAS BE ABLE TO DO
ON ROLE WITH ANOTHER COMMITTEE
COLLEGE BOTH ME COLLEGES WITHIN
THIRTY MILES- IF YOU GO NORTH
YOU GO SOUTH- AND SO A LOT OF
ARE. A LOT OF OUR STUDENTS WANT
TO GO TO THE SOUTH TO COLLEGE
TO THE SECOND COLLEGE. AND
WE'VE TALKED TO THAT THE-
CHANCELLORS OF THE COLLEGES AND
PRESIDENT AND- ONE WON'T
RELEASE US TO BE ABLE TO DO ON
ALL WITH THE SOUTHERN COLLEGE.
INTERESTED FOR THAT PARTICULAR
PROGRAM ANY RATE THE OTHER
CHALLENGES THEY HAVE MAYBE WE
HAVE TWELVE PATHWAYS IN A NINE
INDUSTRY SECTORS THE ONLY LINE
WITH THREE OF OURS. EDITED
TOGETHER TO GET BACK TO MY
POINT EARLIER WHICH WAS. IS IT
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO A LINE OF
THEM ARE THEY SUPPOSED TO
OPERATE HERE. RIGHT IT SEEMS
LIKE. YOU MIGHT BE HEADING THAT
THEY MIGHT BE STUCK IN THEIR
WAYS AND RIGHT IT'S YOUR JOB.
TO MODIFY IT WELL ONE OF THE
ONE OF THE SUGGESTIONS THAT
THEY MADE FOR- TAKING OUR
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
CONSTRUCTION PATHWAY. WAS TOO
THEY HAVE A GREAT SET UP WITH A
WITH FOR YEARS UNIVERSITY
THROUGH THEIR BUSINESS PROGRAM.
SO THEY WERE GONNA TAKE THEY
WANT TO TAKE OUR CONSTRUCTION
STUDENTS PUT HIM INTO THE-
BUSINESS PROGRAM. AND THEN THAT
WILL GET HIM INTO A
CONSTRUCTION- MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM METAPHOR UNIVERSITY.
AND THERE'S NO CONSTRUCTION
MANAGEMENT AT ALL ON THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. CAMPUS SO IT
LITERALLY STOPS THEIR CD
TRAINING SO WHERE'S. THE UNION
STRUCTURE MANAGER IS VERY
DIFFERENT THAN CORRECT WANTING
TO BE A FRAMER FOR PRESS.
CORRECT WHERE THEY CAN GO UNDER
THE UNION AND HAVE THE UNION
COULD THEN EVENTUALLY PAY FOR
THEIR A AND THEIR THEIR-
BACHELOR'S DEGREE AND IF THEY
WANTED TO. CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
SO TO FURTHER EXPAND ON THAT-
CHAIRMAN I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT AND YOU MENTION OUR
GEOGRAPHICAL LOCATION AND
PROXIMITY. IS THIRTY MILES IS
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN
ALL DIRECTIONS- AND WE HAVE FOR
AGRICULTURE PATHWAYS THAT WE
WANT TO ARTICULATE WITH THE
LOCAL CAN YOU COLLEGE IN
SALINAS. SO WE HAVE TO ASK FOR
PERMISSION BE RELEASED ENSURE
THERE WERE ENROLLED IN IN
ARTICULATING WELL WITH THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE THIS
SOUTH IF WE WANT TO GO TO THE
NORTH. THE DANCER COLLEGE WITH
ENGINEERING XINING ETCETERA- WE
AGAIN HAVE TO GO THROUGH THIS
PERMISSION PROCESS- IN FOR US.
WE BELIEVE THAT OUR ROBUST
PROGRAMS ARE GROWING AND WE
WANT OUR STUDENTS TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THOSE PATHWAYS ARTICULATED
SOLIDIFIED. I GO THROUGH THE
PERMISSION PROCESS AND OR HAVE
TO CHANGE OUR PROGRAMS WHICH
ALREADY SOLIDIFIED IN WELL
FUNDED- AND WE BELIEVE THAT'S
NOT IN OUR BEST INTEREST. WE
BELIEVE STUDENTS HAVE THAT
CLEAR CHOICE CAN WE TALK ABOUT
A GROUP OF CHOICE AT ALL TIMES
WITH WILL BE EIGHTY G. WORST HE-
AT SOME. PLEASE ONLY SO THANK
YOU. IT WOULD BACK TO CONSTRUCT
FOR ANY OTHER WELDING. WHICH I
VISITED PRETTY. QUICK IN THAT
ROOM. AND I JUST. I DON'T KNOW
WHY OTHER. A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
WHAT HAVE. YOU KNOW OTHER THAN
YOU HAD OF THEM THE RIVER THAT
WAS SOME PRETTY SERIOUS.
EQUIPMENT WITH SOME PRETTY
SERIOUS TRAINING. AND IF I'D
BEEN THROUGH THAT PROGRAM
PROBABLY TWO YEARS OF THE HIGH
SCHOOL LEVEL. I'M I'M SURE I'M
HIGHER BALL. UPON EXITING HIGH
SCHOOL FOR SURE. BUT WHEN I GO
TO MY COMMUNITY COLLEGE WITH
PROBABLY GOING TO HAPPEN TO
PROM AND I CAN FINISH THAT
CERTIFICATE PROGRAM GOT HIRED
OUT UICKER. BECAUSE IT BECAUSE
THAT BASE THAT THOSE SKILLS I
REALLY LEARNED AT THAT AT THE
HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL YEAH. AND SO
THEN TO REQUIRE YOU TO. THE
FORM TO SOMEBODY ELSE'S MISSION
I'D- I'D- DONE THAT. I'M FINE A
CURIOUS. I JUST OTHER QUESTION
BACK TO THE LOGISTICS OF-
APPLYING FOR THE FUNDING- WHEN
I HEARD OUT THERE IS PEOPLE
HAVE TO WATCH A WEAPON ARE FOR
TWO HOURS EVERY OTHER WEEK OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. AND THEN
YOU APPLY. AND THERE'S A LOT OF
LOGISTICS ASSOCIATED FILLING
OUT THE PAPERWORK CENTER HOURS
AND HOURS AND HOURS YOU HAVE TO
GO TO THESE MEETINGS- AND THEN
YOU END UP WITH. SB SIX
THOUSAND BUCKS. WHERE ON THE C.
TAKE SAID YOU'VE DONE VERY
WELL. COULD YOU ELABORATE ON
THAT WAS KERR. THE. THE
ORIGINAL THE FORM THIS YEAR WAS
BETTER THAN LAST YEAR BUT IT
STILL ASKS THE SAME THINGS
WE'RE STILL MATCHING WITH THE
SAME ADA WE'RE STILL MATCHING
WITH OUR SAME. POPULATION AND-
IT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS THAT
THE C. I PUT THIS. IT'S JUST
SAD. AS DOCTOR DOING ONE. ONLY
BECAUSE OF THE OIL MENTIONED IN
THE SAME TWO AND A HALF MONTH
PERIOD PROP FIFTY ONE KAY TOLD
US TO BE PC DIG AND ALL OF OUR
OTHER GRANTS OR DO AND THE
AMOUNT OF TIME I SPENT ON K.
TWELVE WAS ALMOST TRIPLE THAT I
SPENT ON SEATED. AND THE SAME
WITH THE OTHERS IT WAS JUST.
TRYING TO GET THE MOST FUNDS
FOR OUR STUDENTS AND TO RUN OUR
PROGRAMS IT WAS AT THE CAN
PLEASE WASTE OF TIME. IN THAT
ASPECT IN IRAQ JUST WHAT WAS
YOUR WHAT WAS YOUR AWARD VERSES
AND THE ON THE S. W. P. VERSUS
SEATED. ALL WE GOT OVER TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
ON THE SEATED. AND A STRONG
WORK FOR. SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS
DOLLARS YEAH BUT A LOT MORE
WORK YEAH. IT WAS JUST A-
RESTORATION WHEN YOU SPEND ALL
THE TIME AND BASICALLY THE ONLY
DIFFERENCE IN THE NINE.
DIFFERENT APPLICATIONS THAT I
MADE LAST YEAR WAS THE INDUSTRY
SECTOR BECAUSE IT'S THE SAME
EIGHTY EIGHT THE SAME MATCH THE
SAME STUDENTS THE SAME NUMBERS
SO OR SIMILAR NUMBERS MMHM SO
THAT WAS FRUSTRATING AS WELL
OKAY. IS THERE ANYTHING YOU'D
LIKE TO SHARE BEFORE WE- BRING
UP THE NEXT PANEL I THINK THAT
ONE JUST ONE PIECE- THERE WAS
KIND OF IT WAS ALLUDED TO AND I
CAN'T MEMBER BY WHOM AND THE
PREVIOUS PANEL. THAT SEE TAKEN
STRONG WORK FORCE ARE BOTH
COMPETITIVE FUNDING. AND I WANT
TO DISABUSE ANYONE OF THAT HER
STANDING BECAUSE THE CITY
INCENTIVE GRANTS. DOES FOLLOW
EIGHTY EIGHT IT DOES LOOK AT
EQUITY CONCERNS AND IT DOES
LOOK OUT FROM A PLANNING
PERSPECTIVE HOW YOU MEASURE HOW
YOU REFLECT ON YOUR DEVELOPMENT
YOUR GROWTH IN YOUR OWN
PROGRAMS. HOWEVER AND I
UNDERSTAND IT'S RATED AND SO
FORTH HOWEVER AS A AS DISTRICTS
RESOLUTELY ETS WE HAVE A
GENERAL IDEA OF WHERE WE'RE
GOING TO BE FROM A FUNDING
PERSPECTIVE. YEAR TO YEAR WHICH
REALLY SUPPORTS OUR ABILITY TO
PLAN EFFECTIVELY BUILD OUR
PROGRAMS EFFECTIVELY AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY SUSTAIN THEM-
STRONG WORK FORCE COULD BE ZERO
COULD BE TWO MILLION COULD BE
SIX THOUSAND COULD BE WORKING
OUT IN THE TAIL ON THE- THING.
SO THAT IS A THAT IS NOT THE
SAME THING AND I WANT TO BE
VERY CLEAR ABOUT THAT. THANK
YOU. I WITHOUT THINK MISS
MISTER GOD. OF COURSE REALLY
QUICKLY- WE COULD YOU SPEAK. WE
HAVE EACH OF YOU MAYBE SPEAK TO
THE FUNDING ALLOCATION. THE
PROPOSED FUNDING ALLOCATION FOR
THIS YEAR THE METHODOLOGY AND-
YOU KNOW WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS
MIGHT BE ON HOW HOW THAT
DIFFERENCE IMPACTS SEE TAKE. IN
PARTICULAR. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE HAVE BECAUSE WE WANT
IT'S A AT THE- ONE OF OUR
DISTRICT KIND OF UNDERSTANDINGS
IS THAT. IN ORDER FOR THE
FUNDING TO BE SUSTAINABLE AND-
AND WE WANTED TO BE ON GOING IN
ORDER FOR US TO BE IN
SUSTAINABLE WE DO NOT PUT ANY
PERSONNEL INTO OUR GRANTS- SO
WE BUILD PROGRAMS AND THEN HIRE
THE DISTRICT WILL PAY FOR THAT
PERSONNEL AS WE NEED IT- AND
SO. FIRST SEE TAKE. WE'RE WE'RE
UTILIZING THE FUNDS TO BETTER
OUR PROGRAMS. I AND- WE WORK
WAIT OUR INITIAL WHEN OUR
INITIAL GRANT WE HAD A BOND TO
MATCH SO WE ACTUALLY GOT
CONSIDERABLY MORE. WE HAD A
LITTLE BIT LESS THIS YEAR BUT
WHEN YOU LISTEN TO THERE'S NINE
HUNDRED THOUSAND. DOLLARS BEING
ASKED FOR IT HAS TO BE DIVVIED
UP SOMEONE. BUT IN ORDER FOR TO
BE SUSTAINABLE IT HAS TO ALSO
BE RELIABLE BECAUSE OTHERWISE
IT'S EVEN IF IT'S A EVEN AS WE
ARE SUPPLEMENTING NOT
SUPPLANTING WE STILL NEED TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THAT FUNDING TO.
CONTINUE OUR PROGRAMS AT THAT
LEVEL THAT WE'VE BEEN. THAT
WE'VE BEEN SERVING OUR STUDENTS.
YEAH I THINK SO TO PERSPECTIVES
AGAIN DISTRICT PERSPECTIVE WE
HAVE A VERY SIMILAR MODEL THE
MAJORITY OF OUR- OF OUR
OVERHEAD IS IN GENERAL FUND AND
THIS SEE TAKE FUNDS IN TO HELP
US TO SUPPLEMENT TO ONE OF THE
THINGS I DID HAVE TO HIRE USING
SEE TAKE QUITE FRANKLY WAS A
DATA TECHNICIAN. AND YOU CAN
KIND OF SEE WHY- BUT OVER ALL
WE SUSTAIN OURSELVES AND THAT
IS OUR MATCH THAT'S HOW WE'RE
ABLE TO- RECEIVE THE C. TAKE
FUNDING WITH THE TWO TO ONE
REQUIREMENT AT THE LEVEL THAT
WE- RECEIVE IT OUT IS BECAUSE
WE DO HAVE THAT PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT MATCH ON OUR END- I
WOULD. SHARE WITH YOU THAT I
THINK. I AND I COULD BE
SPEAKING OUT OF TURN HERE BUT I
THINK THAT WE ARE IN SOME WAYS
AN ANOMALY AS I SPEAK TO OTHERS
SEE TV COUNCIL MEMBERS- THROUGH
ACTS THAT THERE ARE MANY
DISTRICTS THAT REALLY SURVIVE
AND THEIR EMPLOYEES AND THEIR
TEACHERS ARE FUNDED OUT OF. THE
CITY INCENTIVE GRANT FUNDING
OUT OF STRONG WORK FORCE AND
SO- I'M- THAT'S WHERE THE
COMMENT CAME FROM- WITH REGARDS
TO THEIR FEAR THAT THEIR
PROGRAMS WERE ACTUALLY COLLAPSE.
YEAH AND I THINK JUST ALLEN IN
MY COLLEAGUES. ARE VERY CORRECT
IN IN TERMS OF THE ALLOCATION
THROUGH OUR GENERAL FUND SO.
THAT WE MAY TO CONDEMN WITH OUR
BOARD OF TRUSTEES- IT'S A
PATHWAY AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
FOR US AS FAR AS GRADUATION IS
CONCERNED SO WE'RE FINDING
EVERYONE OF OUR ELEVEN. FULL
TIME TEACHERS OUT OF OUR
GENERAL FUND WHICH ALSO HAS A
COMPETING INTERESTS WITH
SPECIAL EDUCATION STIRS AND
PURRS. AND ALL OF THE OTHER
OBLIGATIONS THAT WE HAVE- IN
THIS THIS SOME WOMEN. ARE
MENTIONED- THREE FOUR YEARS AGO
WE PUT UP. MILLION ORDER. I'M
NOT. WAS A COMMITMENT BY THE
CAN YOU THE A LOCAL JAIL BY. TO
REALLY SUPPORT KRYCEK READ. AND
WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR MISSION. TO
REALLY PROVIDE THOSE GREATEST
RANGE OF OPTIONS WE CARE YEAR
TO YEAR. RELY ON THE
SUSTAINABILITY OF C. TAKE OR K.
TWELVE- APPLICATION MONIES. SO
WE'VE MADE THAT OBLIGATION
CLEAR IN OUR GENERAL FUND BUT
HAVING SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
THROUGH THE SEA TAKE WOULD
REALLY BE BENEFICIAL. YEAH AND
I THINK THE KEY WORD THERE IS
SUSTAINABLE AND RELIABLE AND SO
WHEN WE HAVE HUGE DIPS LIKE 83%
LOSS. HERE FROM YEAR TO YEAR
YES SOME IS A 75% LOSS- IN THAT
SEE TAKE FUNDING THAT'S NOT
GOING TO BUILD A SUSTAINABLE
PROGRAM RIGHT THE OTHER. IF I
MAY ADD THEIR EXPENSIVE
PROGRAMS THEY'RE VERY EXPENSIVE
PROGRAMS SO WITHOUT THAT
FUNDING I DON'T KNOW HOW WE
WOULD. KEEP IT GOING. SO YOU'RE-
THANK YOU WELL THANK YOU DR TO
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE TODAY
FOR CUT YOUR DEAL RULES I
APPRECIATE AXES ENGAGEMENT ON
THIS THOSE ARE THE INFORMED
VOICES ON THE GROUND IN A
COMING BACK AND SHARING THEIR
EXPERIENCES AND I WELCOME THAT
WE NEED THAT BECAUSE- YOU KNOW
IT'S A DO YOU ARE ONE OF OUR
PARTNERS IN HELPING SHAPE
POLICY FOR SURE AND ALSO SALMON
YOU KNOW HIGH SCHOOL U. S. TO A
GREAT JOB OUT THERE REALLY
COMPREHENSIVE SIGNIFICANTLY. IN
A REAL COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAMS
OUT THERE THAT ARE REALLY
GETTING KIDS READY FOR THE WORK
FORCE OR OR EVEN MOVING MOVING
ON A TO HIGHER EDUCATION
BECAUSE A SKILLS A LEARNING
YOUR CLASSROOMS THEY CAN CARRY
THROUGH THEIR LIFE AND IT IS
SOME BIG STUFF GOIN ON OUT
THERE SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INVITATION OUT THERE THREE FOUR
MONTHS AGO AND THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY OUR
INFORMATION. THANK YOU. IT WILL
THAT WILL INTRODUCE A- TH.
PANEL CAN PREPARE TO GO UP OUR
THIRD PANEL ON SUPPORTING K.
TWELVE C. T. PROGRAMS SO WE'LL
HAVE- LINDA GRANGER OF THE
EATING AREA ARE OP. AND THEN
WILL HAVE VALERIE. RESEARCH
SUCH OF THE- FRESNO COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION. YOU MAY.
START WHEN READY THEY WERE
START WITH MISS GRANGER. AND
EMIGRATE GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS LINDA
GRANGER AND I AM THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF EATING AREA
REGIONAL OCCUPATIONAL PROGRAM.
WE REPRESENT FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THE EAST BAY
CASTRO VALLEY HEY WORD SAN
LEANDRO IN SAN LORENZO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS COMBINED THESE
DISTRICTS SERVE ROUGHLY TWENTY
TWO THOUSANDS STUDENTS IN
GRADES SEVEN THROUGH TWELVE
WITH FORTY EIGHT HUNDRED
STUDENTS PARTICIPATING IN
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
EIGHT NERI ROP HAS BEEN
SUPPORTING THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF C. T. E. IN THESE DISTRICTS
FOR FIFTY YEARS AND HAS WORK
COLLECTIVELY TO IMPLEMENT
SEATED FROM ITS INCEPTION AND
WAS AWARDED THE STRONG WORK
FORCE GRANT LAST YEAR. I WOULD
LIKE TO BEGIN BY STATING THAT I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THE
CONCEPT OF COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND K. TWELVE SYSTEMS WORKING
GET TOGETHER TO ALIGN AND
SUPPORT IMPROVE STUDENT
OUTCOMES VIA PARTICIPATION IN
C. T. E. PATHWAYS. I THINK THE
CD E. IN THE REGION LEADS OF
THE COMMUNICABLE ITS LEVEL ARE
DOING THEIR BEST TO TAKE ON THE
TASK OF COORDINATING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE SEATED
AND THE K. TWELVE STRONG WORK
FORCE PROGRAMS. YET THERE ARE
MANY CHALLENGES WITH THE
CURRENT TO SYSTEM APPROACH TO
SEE T. E. IN THE SEATED PROGRAM
WHAT WAS VIEWED BY MANY IN THE
FIELD AS AN EFFECTIVE TECHNICAL
US SINCE PROGRAM HAS BEEN
ELIMINATED. THE REGIONAL
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
PREVIOUSLY OFFERED NO LONGER
EXISTS. ADDITIONALLY THERE IS A
LACK OF INFRASTRUCTURE ON THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SITE TO
IMPLEMENT THE K. TWELVE STRONG
WORK FORCE. I WOULD LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT THREE CHALLENGES WITH
THE SWP ONE TIMING UNDER THE
CURRENT STRUCTURE WE HAVE TAKEN
ON GO FUNDING AND TURNED IT
INTO ONE TIME COME. GRANT WITH
THREE MONTHS WINDOW. DOES
DIFFICULT TO ACHIEVE STUDENT
OUTCOMES OUTLINED IN THE GRANT
OVER SUCH A SHORT TIME PERIOD.
IT'S ALSO CHALLENGING TO MAKE A
LONGER TERM PLANNING DECISIONS
THAT INCLUDE STAFFING WITH
CURRENT WITH THE UNCERTAINTY IT
LOOK FUNDING IN THIS PROGRAM.
TO THE APPLICATION PROCESS IN
SELECTING A WILL BE. IF ALLEGED
NOT INTERESTED IN WORKING YOU.
KNOW WHAT TO OF. THE P. WHO
DIED FOR. OUR THE SIR. SELECT
COMMITTEE AND THE TERM WHO GETS
FOR. THIS IS CON OF IN AND P.
AGAIN EACH OTHER. EACH READ
THROUGHOUT THE STATE HAS
INCREDIBLE LATITUDE TO
DETERMINE HOW THE GRANTS ARE
ALLOCATED WHICH LEADS TO
INCONSISTENCY AND HOW PROGRAMS
ARE FUNDED. IN OUR REGION THE
COMMITTEE DECIDED TO FUND ALL
OF THE GRANTS THAT MET THE
MINIMUM QUALIFYING SCORE FOR
FUNDING TO SOME DEGREE SMALL
GRANTS. FOR FULL FUNDED IN THE
LARGER TOWNS WERE FUNDED AT
LESS THAN HALF OF WHAT THEY
APPLIED FOR. IN AN EFFORT TO
MAKE THE PROCESS LESS
CUMBERSOME THIS YEAR THE GRANT
APPLICATION WAS REVISED TO
RESEMBLE A WORK PLAN FORMAT
WITH A FEW QUESTIONS WITH
EXTREMELY LIMITED SPACE TO
RESPOND TO THE PROPS ABOUT
FOURTEEN HUNDRED CHARACTERS.
THEY ALSO CHANNEL CHANGE THE
MAXIMUM AMOUNT YOU CAN APPLY
FOR REDUCING IT TO TWO MILLION
DOLLARS PER APPLICATION FROM
THE FIVE MILLION MAXIMUM OF
LAST YEAR AND A LIMIT OF NO
MORE THAN THREE APPLICATIONS
PER DISK. THIS DISCOURAGES
REGIONAL COLLABORATION. THAT I
BELIEVE THE LEGISLATION
INTENDED TO ENCOURAGE AS EACH
OF MY DISTRICT COULD
INDIVIDUALLY APPLIED FOR A NEW
AND GRANT ON HER EIGHT EIGHT
YEAH COLOR. BUT THE PLOY TO IN
THE MAPS ONLY SIX MAY. MILLION
DOLLARS FOR K. TWELVE PATHWAY
COORDINATOR FOR EACH COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT GIVEN THEIR
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
WITH ONLY ONE COLLEGE AND
DISTRICTS WITH MULTIPLE
COLLEGES HAVING ONE POSITION
PER DISTRICT IS ALSO A
CHALLENGE. WE ARE HALFWAY
THROUGH THE SECOND YEAR OF THIS
PROGRAM AND WE JUST GOT
GUIDANCE ON SELECTING THE HOST
AGENCIES FOR THESE POSITIONS ON
DECEMBER TWENTIETH WITH THE
GOAL OF HAVING THAT PERSON
SELECTED AND READY TO START ON
MAY FIRST. EACH HOST ELLIE A IS
ALSO BEING ALLOCATEDA HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR FOR THIS
POSITION WAS SEVENTY TWO
POSITIONS THAT EQUATES TO NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IT IS UNCLEAR
TO ME HOW THE REMAINING THREE
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR IS
BEING USED FOR THIS PURPOSE
MUCH LESS HOW THE FUNDS FROM
THE FIRST YEAR. HAVE BEEN
UTILIZED I'VE PROVIDED ALL OF
THESE EXAMPLES TO ILLUSTRATE
THE CHALLENGES IN IMPLEMENTING
THE PROGRAM AS IT CURRENTLY
STANDS IT IS DIFFICULT IN
ENOUGH FOR IN YOU TO BE
ACCOUNTABLE TO YOU OR A- YEP
THE SPECTER TO BE. FUN AMONG
PRO I'M WHEN THE DEAN IS AND
CERTAIN AND DESPITE OF ALL
ALLEN I AM EIGHT FOUR STATE
RECOGNIZE THE VALUABLE WE'LL
SEE T. E. PLAYS IN OUR STUDENTS
EDUCATION. WE ARE IN THE RIGHT
TO. WE JUST NEED TO PER GREAT
STE. FOR C. T. PRO THAT WE CAN
PH<c.cyan>N OUT OVER TIME. TO THIS</c>
END. TO JUST YOU CAN HOW FOR
DECISIONS ARE MAY.
CONSOLIDATING ON ONE. WITH A
ANNUAL ALLOCATE SEEM AS IF IT
WOULD BE THE MOST EFFECTIVE
RESOLUTION. THIS WOULD ENABLE
DISTRICTS TO PROVIDE MORE LONG
TERM PLANNING TO MEET THEIR
STUDENT NEEDS. WHILE ALSO
PROVIDING ACCOUNTABILITY
PROVISIONS TO ENSURE DISTRICTS
ARE PROVIDING QUALITY C. T. E.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WELL DONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR DONALD AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS VALERIE VIEW SICH I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR KERR
TECHNICAL EDUCATION AND
REGIONAL OCCUPATIONAL PROGRAM
R. O. P. AND I'M ALSO THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
CAREER AND TECHNICAL
ORGANIZATION ARE PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATION THANK YOU FOR THE
INVITATION TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY AND SHARE THE PERSPECTIVE
FROM THE COUNTY OFFICE. LEVEL
I'VE WORKED IN THIS FIELD FOR
OVER THIRTY YEARS OF MY CAREER
FOR THE LAST FOURTEEN OF SERVED
AS THE ADMINISTRATOR OF THE
FRESNO R. O. P. PROGRAM. IN
THAT PROGRAM I OF TWENTY TWO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS OVER THREE
COUNTIES FRESNO MADERA AND
MARIPOSA IN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA.
AND WE ALSO HAD THE PLEASURE OF
SERVING AS ONE OF THE SEVEN
SEATED REGIONAL TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS DURING ITS
FUNDED TERM OF TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN THROUGH NINETEEN THAT
PROGRAM ENDED LAST JUNE
THIRTIETH. AT FRESNO COUNTY WE
ARE ALSO THE LEAD AGENCY FOR A
SEAT TAKE CONSORTIUM OF
SEVENTEEN OF MY SMALL
DISTRICTS. WHO WERE NOT ABLE TO
APPLY ON THEIR OWN. FOR SEATED
FUNDS WITH THE ADVENT OF THE K.
TWELVE STRONGWORK FORCE
PROGRAM I'VE ALSO BEEN
FORTUNATE TO BE SELECTED AS A
MEMBER OF CENTRAL MOTHER LODE
K. TWELVE SELECTION COMMITTEE
FOR THESE FIRST TWO FUNDING
CYCLES. IN FOR TRANSPARENCY WE
WERE UNSUCCESSFUL APPLICANT FOR
STRONG WORK FORCE FUNDS LAST
YEAR AND DID NOT SUBMIT AN
APPLICATION FOR THIS CURRENT
ROUND. AS THE SEA TO TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TEAM MY STAFF SERVED
OVER SIXTY FIVE LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE TEN
COUNTY AREA OF CENTRAL VALLEY
FROM BAKER STILL TO STOCKTON.
THE C. TAKE OUR TAPS WERE
FUNDED AT THREE MILLION DOLLARS
PER YEAR WITH THE FUNDS
DISTRIBUTED ACROSS THE SEVEN
COUNTY OFFICES BASED UPON THE
NUMBER OF ELEAZAR AND AMOUNT OF
ADA IN THEIR RESPECTIVE
REGIONS. EACH ARE TAP HAD THE
FLEXIBILITY TO DESIGN THEIR
SERVICES TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THE RECIPIENTS IN THEIR REGION
AND IN MY OFFICE WE WERE ABLE
TO USE THE EXPERTISE AVAILABLE
ACROSS MY MANAGEMENT TEAM WHICH
ALLOWED PER WRITER VARIETY OF
PROFESSIONAL. EXPERTISE FOR
PARTNERS IN THE REGION WE BE
NIMBLE AND MATCH THE STAFF
MEMBER TO THIS. NEED THE YEAH.
PERSON HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
EVERYTHING ABOUT ALL ASK OF C.
T. AND WE COULD WERE
COLLECTIVELY. TO SHARE OUR NO
AND- THE SEVEN SEAT TO GUARD
TAPS ALSO COORDINATED OR WORK
WITH EACH OTHER AND MET
FREQUENTLY WITH CD STAFF IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE CONSISTENT
INFORMATION AND MESSAGING. TO
ELLIE IS IN THE STATE REGARDING
C. T. RULES REGULATIONS AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE ELEVEN
ELEMENTS OF A HIGH QUALITY C.
T. PROGRAM. WE WERE ABLE TO
SHARE INFORMATION WITH EACH
OTHER AND QUESTIONS RAISED IN
THE FIELD AS WELL AS DEVELOPING
SURE MATERIALS. THAT WE COULD
UTILIZE IN PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT ACTIVITIES. THE C.
TAKE OUR TAPS ARE ALL
EXPERIENCED PRACTITIONERS WHO
OF WALK THE TALK. IN THE NEW
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THAT WILL
BECOME AVAILABLE- MS GRANGER
ALREADY SPOKE ABOUT THE
TIMELINE IN THE PROCESS- WE ARE
ONE OF THE REGION'S HE WAS
FORTUNATE TO HAVE THE ONE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDER
IN PLACE. AT THIS TIME THOUGH
ONE YEAR AFTER THOSE FUNDS WERE
SUPPOSED TO HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED WE'RE WITHOUT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN THE
STATE. WE WERE CAUTIONED BY
SOME OF OUR K. FOURTEEN
PARTNERS TO NOT CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
OUR COLLEAGUES AS THAT WAS NOW
THEIR- TERRITORY AND WE
SHOULDN'T BE IMPEDING. ON THOSE
ROLES. SO WHAT IS HAPPENED IS
AS WE HAVE TRIED TO MOVE
FORWARD WE'RE NOT GOING TO
ALLOW OUR COLLEAGUES TO FAIL SO
WEAK UIETLY ANSWER QUESTIONS
IF WE CAN'T AND REFER. TO THEIR
K. FOURTEEN PARTNERS. AS AS
WE'VE TRIED TO MOVE FORWARD. ON
IF. IT IS NOT UNUSUAL TO
RECEIVE A FOLLOW UP CALL AFTER
THAT REFERRAL BECAUSE THE ONLY
A EITHER DIDN'T GET A RESPONSE
THE RESPONSE WAS NOT COMPLETE
OR IT WAS PERHAPS INCORRECT. AS
WE ALL ATTEMPT TO NAVIGATE THE
NEW FUNDING STREAMS FOR C. T.
E. IT'S CLEAR THAT ARE TWO
SYSTEMS HAVE DIFFERENT
CULTURES. ON THE K. TWELVE SIDE
WERE SYSTEM OF ACCOUNTABILITY
AND COMPLIANCE AS EVIDENCED BY
THE STATE DASHBOARD DATA
ELEMENTS. THE PURPOSE OF K.
TWELVE EDUCATION IS TO PREPARE
STUDENTS FOR BOTH COLLEGE AND
CAREER AND OUR GOAL IS TO HELP
STUDENTS EXPLORE THEIR
INTERESTS AND TALENTS WHILE
PROVIDING THE INFORMATION ABOUT
HOW THEY RELATE TO I'D VARIETY
OF CAREER PATHWAYS. WITHIN
INDUSTRY SECTORS AND WHERE THEY
CAN GO TO PURSUE THEM FOLLOWING
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION. K.
TWELVE CT PROGRAMS INCLUDE THE
PARTICIPATION OF INDUSTRY
PARTNERS AND WE PLACE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS IN
WORK SITES AS A COMPONENT OF
MANY OF OUR R. O. P. CLASSES.
THE PURPOSE OF THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE SYSTEM IS TO PROVIDE
COURSE WORK THAT ALLOWS ADULTS
TO PURSUE ACADEMIC PATH FOR
TRANSFER TO A FOUR YEAR
COLLEGE. OR UNIVERSITY OR SEEK
JOB TRAINING SKILLS THAT CAN
RESULT IN CERTIFICATION AND JOB
ADVANCEMENT. COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE REQUIRED TO BE FOCUSED ON
THEIR GEOGRAPHIC BOUNDARIES
WHEN THEY CONSIDER THE C. T.
PATHWAYS THEY WILL OFFER. IT IS
NOT OUR ROLE IN K. TWELVE
EDUCATION TO LIMIT STUDENTS TO
OUR LOCAL REGION. AS THEY
PURSUE THEIR LONG TERM
EDUCATIONAL AND OR EMPLOYMENT
GOALS. SO FAR OUR EXPERIENCE IS
THAT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FOLKS HAVE A FOCUS ON STRONG
WORK FORCE WHICH IS
UNDERSTANDABLE SINCE THAT IS
THEIR PROGRAM. THERE USED TO
OPERATING UNDER THOSE
PARAMETERS THEIR KNOWLEDGE OF
K. TWELVE PROGRAMS REGULATIONS
CREDENTIALING REQUIREMENTS AND
ACCOUNTABILITY REQUIREMENTS
APPEARS TO BE LIMITED OR
NONEXISTENT. THERE'S BEEN A
RELUCTANCE TO ENGAGE IN C. TAKE
CONVERSATIONS AS THEY DO NOT
THINK THAT SEE TAKE IS THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY. PARTICULARLY IN
THE REGION'S YOU'VE NOT HIRED
THERE K. FOURTEEN TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PERSON THE COMMON
RESPONSE FROM THE STRONG WORK
FORCE REGIONAL COORDINATOR K.
TWELVE PARTNERS IS TO CALL CD.
THE K. TWELVE STRONG WORK FORCE
GRANT SELECTION PROCESS AS
YOU'VE HEARD HAS BEEN
PROBLEMATIC FOR K. TWELVE DALY
ACE. AND THE FACT THAT EACH
REGION OPERATES A LITTLE
DIFFERENTLY FROM THE OTHERS
CAUSES CONFUSION AND
FRUSTRATION ON THE PART OF THE
K. TWELVE APPLICANTS WHEN WE'RE
TOGETHER IT STATE WIDE MEETINGS
AND BEGIN DISCUSSING OUR K.
TWELVE GRANTS. THERE'S NOT A
CONSISTENCY IN THE INFORMATION
THAT WE ALL RECEIVE. IT'S NOT
UNCOMMON TO HEAR THAT SOMETHING
PRESENTED AT A STATE MEETING IS
NOT THE SAME INFORMATION THAT
ARE STRONG WORK FORCE REGIONAL
COORDINATORS FEEL THEY'RE BEING
TOLD. SOME REGIONS HAVE VERY
BALLOT SELECTION COMMITTEES
BETWEEN K. TWELVE AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE MEMBERS AND OTHERS HAVE
THE MINIMUM K. TWELVE
PARTICIPANTS WITH THE MAJORITY
OF THE MEMBERS COMING FROM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. THERE
APPEARS TO BE A LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING BY DECEMBER MANY
OF THOSE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FOLKS THAT IT ISN'T THEIR
MONEY. AND THE GRANTS NEED TO
LOOK LIKE THEIR GRANTS AGAIN IT
COMES BACK TO A LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT OUR PURPOSE
AND FOCUS AT THE K. TWELVE
LEVEL. WELL THE ONLINE
APPLICATION WAS MODIFIED AS A
RESULT OF FEEDBACK FROM PRIOR
APPLICANTS FOR THE CURRENT
PHASE IT'S STILL REQUIRES MANY
HOURS TO COMPLETE. LAST YEAR WE
HEARD FROM COLLEAGUES IT'S BEEN
AS MANY AS TWO HUNDRED HOURS
COMPLETING THE APPLE. IT'S RARE
FOR KATE DISTRICTS TO HAVE
PROFESSIONAL GRANT WRITERS ON
STAFF PARTICULARLY SMALL. WORLD
SOMETHING THAT MADE COMMON FOR
MANY COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
SO THE TASK OFTEN FALLSTO
CLASSROOM TEACHERS AND MANY OF
MY SMALL SCHOOLS. THE CURRENT
APPLICATION NO NEAR. FOR THE
YEAR TWO ABLE TO AND- HOW APPLE
RIGHT AT THE NOT THERE'S-
ANOTHER. CONCERN KATE ELLIOT TO
DO RESEARCH THE FUNDS ARE THE
MATRIX REQUIRE TO BE REPORTED.
AS A K. TWELVE PROGRAM I WILL
GET CREDIT. FOR C. T. PATHWAYS.
TO FROM MY PRO HAVING. TO OR
MORE CTK. IN THE SAME PATHWAY.
I DON'T GET CREDIT IF THEY GO
STRAIGHT TO WORK OR IF THEY
ENROLL IN A FOUR YEAR COLLEGE
OR UNIVERSITY. WAS OPTION ONLY
OUT. TOWARDS SUCCESS OF MY
PROGRAM IF THE STUDENT
COMPLETED A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROGRAM FIRST. FOR THE LATEST
ROUND OF K. TWELVE STRONG WORK
FORCE WE'RE SEEING A REDUCTION
IN THE NUMBER OF APPLICATIONS
AND AS WE'VE HEARD SOME OF THIS
MAY BE DUE TO THE NEW LIMITS ON
HOW MANY APPLICATIONS. CAN BE
SUBMITTED FOR ELLIE A AND SOME
MAY NOT THINK THAT THEIR
SPECIFIC PROJECT CAN BE
COMPLETED WITHIN THE
CONSTRAINTS OF THE NEW MAXIMUM
ALLOCATIONS THEY QUALIFY TO
APPLY FOR. EXCUSE WE WILL ONLY
BE ABLE TO EVALUATE THE SMALLER
NUMBERS ONCE THE AWARDS PROCESS
IS COMPLETED AND SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS CAN BE ASKED OF
ELLIOT. I MENTIONED APPLYING
FOR THE C. TOGETHER CONSORTIUM
EARLIER. UNDER THE NEW FUNDING
PARAMETERS FOR K. TWELVE STRONG
WORK FORCE. FORMING A
CONSORTIUM TO APPLY MAY
ACTUALLY CREATE MORE
LIMITATIONS THAN IF THE
INDIVIDUAL PARTNERS APPLIED ON
THEIR OWN. AND THAT'S AN ISSUE
THAT SUPERINTENDENT GRANGER
ALREADY SHARED WITH YOU. A
LARGER ISSUE FOR MANY OF MY
DISTRICTS IS HAVING THE
MATCHING FUNDS AVAILABLE. WELL
SEATED DOLLARS ARE COMPETITIVE
BECAUSE WE SUBMIT AN
APPLICATION WE ALL KNOW THAT WE
WILL RECEIVE AN ALLOCATION IF
WE MEET. MY QUALIFY. SUCH
GUARANTEE IN THE TWELVE STRONG
WORK FORCE PROCESS. AND THE
ONLY A MAY CHOOSE TO MAXIMIZE
THEIR SEATED MATCH IN ORDER TO
NOT HURT THEIR CHANCES OF
RECEIVING A LARGER AWARD. AND
DUE TO THE TIMING OF THESE TWO
APPLICATION PROCESS SEES NOT
KNOWING HOW MUCH THEY REALLY
WILL NEED FOR C. TO. AND WHAT
THEY COULD HAVE HAD AVAILABLE
FOR K. TWELVE STRONG WORK FORCE
COMES INTO PLAY. BY THE TIME
ONE PROCESS FINISHES THE OTHER
APPLICATION HAS ALREADY BEEN DO
SO IT'S ALL A GUESSING GAME.
THROUGH IN THE LOCAL MATCH FOR
PROP FIFTY ONE FACILITIES AND
MANY ELEAZAR TAPPED OUT. THEY
CAN'T AFFORD TO HOLD MATCH
DOLLARS BACK FOR THE
POSSIBILITY OF A K. TWELVE
STRONG WORK FORCE APPLICATION.
NEITHER OF THESE FUNDING
SOURCES ARE STABLE FOR THE
RECIPIENTS THE ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS EACH
PROGRAM REMAINS THE SAME BUT
HOW THE FUNDS ARE DIVIDED UP
CHANGES ON AN ANNUAL BASIS.
THIS IS NOT A FUNDING STRUCTURE
THAT ALLOWS FOR LONG TERM
PLANNING. COLLEAGUE ONCE SAID
YOU DON'T SPEND A GIFT CARD THE
SAME WAY YOU SPEND A PAYCHECK.
K. TWELVE STRONG WORK FORCES
DEFINITELY A GIFT CARD. WE HOPE
SEATED WOULD HAVE BECOME THE
PAYCHECK BUT WITH THE
FLUCTUATING FUNDING AWARDS
BASED ON THE NUMBER OF
PARTICIPANTS ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS. AND THE CHANGES IN
EIGHTY EIGHT FROM YEAR TO YEAR.
IT'S TURNED OUT TO BE THE GIFT
CARD THAT YOU KNOW YOU'RE GOING
TO RECEIVE YOU JUST DON'T KNOW
HOW MUCH IT WILL BY. WE'VE GONE
FROM AN R. O. P. SYSTEM OF
SEVENTY FOUR PROGRAMS THAT WAS
FUNDED AT FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR LEVEL. TO
A C. T. E. SYSTEM FUNDING OVER
A HUNDRED PROGRAMS. AT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS. BECAUSE THE STRONG
WORK FORCE PIECE IS STILL
ALWAYS A FLUCTUATING NUMBER.
THE SMALL AND MEDIUM SCHOOLS
WITHIN MY SEE TAKE CONSORTIUM
DO NOT RECEIVE ENOUGH NINE
TWELVE SUPPLEMENTAL DOLLARS. TO
MAKE UP FOR THE SHORTFALL. THAT
THIS OVERALL REDUCTION IN C. T.
FUNDING HAS CREATED. AS YOU
CONTINUE TO STUDY THIS. CITY
ACROSS THE STATE AND ENVISIONED
WHAT ACTIONS YOU COULD TAKE TO
IMPROVE THE SUSTAINABILITY OF
THE INVESTMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE. OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS
I HOPE YOU SERIOUSLY CONSIDER
CONSOLIDATING THE FUNDS
AVAILABLE TO K. TWELVE VALLEY
ETS. INTO ONE FUNDING STREAM
BASED UPON THE SEAT HE
ENROLLMENT WITHIN DISTRICTS AND
PROGRAMS AND CREATE AN
ALLOCATION PROCESS THAT IS FAIR
BUT ALSO MORE PREDICTABLE FOR
THE STABILITY OF PROGRAMS OVER
THE LONG. HAUL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. VERY VERY THOROUGH WELL.
THANK YOU- ONE ASK YOU MISS
GRANGER- DO YOU FEEL THAT ARE-
PEAS OR OTHER CONSORTIUM MODELS
ARE. AT A DISADVANTAGE UNDER
THE STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM.
YES THEY ARE YEAH- YOU IT
YOU'RE TRYING TO ENCOURAGE
REGIONAL COLLABORATION IN TERMS
OF THE LANGUAGE BUT WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE FUNDING
AVAILABLE- AS A CONSORTIUM THE
MAXIMUM AMOUNT WE CAN APPLY FOR
IS TWO MILLION DOLLARS TO BE
SPENT OVER TWO. HALF YEARS SO
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT HOW MANY
STUDENTS ARE TRYING TO SUPPORT
ACROSS FOR DISTRICTS IN IN A
PROGRAM THAT DOESN'T TAKE YOU
VERY FAR. SO THAT'S A
DISADVANTAGE WHERE EACH OF MY
DISTRICT THAT THEY APPLIED
INDIVIDUALLY BASED ON THEIR
EIGHTY EIGHT THEY COULD APPLY
FOR TWO MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THEIR DISTRICT ALONE. SO IT'S
DOES NOT SUPPORT REGIONAL
COLLABORATION OR BIG GROUPS
WORKING TOGETHER I UNDERSTAND I
UNDERSTAND KIND OF DYNAMIC
THERE TO GREET. ME AND FOR MISS
OF USAGE. I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
COLLEGE. THAT THAT THE COLLEGES
HAVE A TOTAL OF THIRTY THIRTEEN
POINT FIVE MILLION A YEAR FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WHEN
COUNTY OFFICES WERE PROVIDING.
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR THE
INCENTIVE PROGRAM TO CD WHAT
WAS DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE TOTAL
ANNUAL COST WAS IT WAS A THREE
MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET A YEAR
DIVIDED UP AMONGST THE SEVEN
COUNTIES BASED ON- 70% WAS
BASED ON. THE NUMBER OF ELEAZAR
IN YOUR REGION AND THE OTHER
30% WAS BASED ON THE ACTUAL
EIGHTY EIGHT. THE HIGH SCHOOL
SEVEN TWELVE. IN ANY TEST
WHETHER YOU'RE GIVING SO WELL.
I DON'T SPEAK FOR YOU ITS
SECRET TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
BECAUSE- WE'RE QUIET TECHNICALS
WAS IN ORDER I DON'T KNOW. YEAH
I MEAN WE WERE KIND OF TRYING
TO NAVIGATE THAT FINE LINE
BETWEEN HELPING FOLKS BUT NOT
APPEARING AS THOUGH YOU'RE
HELPING FOR SALE THE OFFICIAL.
YOU KNOW TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
UNTIL I DON'T KNOW WHY ANYONE
WOULD FIND FAULT WITH SOMEONE
HELPING ANYONE ELSE. HELP KIDS
BUT THAT'S WE THAT'S ANOTHER
CONVERSATION IF THAT'S NOT
CONSISTENT ACROSS ALL REGIONS
IF I UNDERSTOOD PERSONALITY
THING IT'S AN ODD DYNAMIC TO
HAVE A GOVERNMENT THAT SUPPOSED
TO SERVE PEOPLE- BUT- YOU TALK
WHAT DO YOU TALK ABOUT THE
CONFLICT IN THE SELECTION
COMMITTEE COULD YOU JUST.
ELABORATE ON THAT FUHRMAN YEAH
WHEN YOU THE SELECTION
COMMITTEE IS COMPRISED OF A
GROUP OF VOLUNTEERS FROM WITHIN
THE REGION AND WHAT'S HAPPENED
IN OUR REGION THE IS THAT THE
PEOPLE WHO FROM THE K. TWELVE
SIDE- EVERYBODY WHO'S ON THE
COMMITTEE ARE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
APPLIED FOR THE GRANT. AND SO
THAT JUST CREATE CON OF IT NOW
YOU DON'T GET TO READ AND SCORE
YOUR OWN GRANT BUT YOU'RE
BRINGING THAT PERSPECTIVE INTO
THE PROCESS- SOME OF THE
EXAMPLES OF THIS ROUND OUR-
THIS PLANET HAVE THE. THE
CALLER. OUT IT IS WHAT IS THE
GOING TO DO AND IF YOU APPLY IS
A CONSORTIUM SOME ENTER THAT TO
BEING THE LEADER OF THE GROUP
AND THEN THERE'S A COLUMN FOR
WHAT YOUR PARTNERS ARE GOING TO
DO IT AND THAT WAS INTERPRETED
AS YOUR DISTRICT YOU'RE WORKING
WHAT WELL IF YOU'RE INDIVIDUAL-
DISTRICT THAT'S SUPPLIED YOU
INTERPRETED THOSE TWO COLUMNS
DIFFERENTLY THAT HERE'S WHAT
I'M GONNA DO AND THEN HERE'S
WHAT MY COMMUNITY PARTNERS ARE
GOING TO DO AND OR YOU PUT IN A
BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE ANY
PARTNERS SO HOW DO YOU SCHOOL.
IN PEOPLE OKAY BRING THAT LENDS
TO WELL THEY SHOULD HAVE DONE
IT THE WAY I DID IT AND SO
THERE THIS DEBATE IS GOING ON
WITHIN THE REGION ON HOW YOU
SCORE THE PRO. THERE'S ALSO A
PUSH THAT THERE. WELL AREAS OF
OUR REGION COST LASHED AND ONES
IN SO WE REALLY NEED TO LOOK AT
WHO WASN'T FUNDED AND IT'S
BECOMES WELL IF YOU'RE IF I'M
GONNA LOOK AT THAT THEN WHY ARE
WE MAKING THIS A COMPETITIVE
SAYS THAT YOU APPLY FOR. YOU
SHOULD MAKE IT AN ALLOCATION IN
THE COLLEGE CITED IS AN
ALLOCATION BASED ON THEIR
ENROLLMENT IN THEIR DISTRICTS
THAT'S HOW THE STRONG WORK
FORCE PROGRAM WORKS ON THEIR
SITE SO WHY IS IT DIFFERENT FOR
US. SO THERE WAS A COMMENT. NO
THE PORTION OF COMMERCE WHERE
YOU ELUDED. WITH THAT THE
STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM
REWARDS STUDENTS GOING ON A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR NOT SAY A
FOUR YEAR SCHOOL OR ANY OTHER
WORKFORCE OR EVEN INTO. ON TO A
TRADE SCHOOL. ACT THEY'VE GONE
GRADUATION FROM HIGH SCHOOL THE
WAY THE METRICS ARE SIGNED UP
THAT WE ALL AGREED TO WHEN WE
APPLY FOR THE DOLLARS- THE HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATES THAT COMPLETE
THEIR PATHWAYS AND GRADUATE
FROM HIGH SCHOOL IS SOMEONE I
CAN COUNT YOU. IDIOT LEE BUT
ALL OF THE OTHER PIECE GOING
INTO APPRENTICESHIP GOING INTO
THE MATCH TERRY GOING INTO FOUR
YEAR PROGRAM GRADUATING
COMMUNITY COLLEGE THOSE OTHER
PIECES ONLY CAME. UPON OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROGRAM. IN
THE SAME THREE SECTOR WAY. SO
IF I HAVE A STUDENT WHO
COMPLETES- HELP OUT THE HIGH
SCHOOL FOR EXAMPLE. AND PERHAPS
CHANGES OVER TO OF BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION MAJOR AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND FINISHES
THEIR PROGRAM THERE. IF THEY
WERE PART OF MY K. TWELVE
LOCATION. I'M NOT GET TO KEEP
THEM. AS A SIX. I PROGRAM. ON
THEIR GRAD FROM THE CALL AS
THEY DID A THE SAME INDUSTRY SO.
AND YOU KNOW WE CAN'T CONTROL
WHERE STUDENTS ON WHAT THEY DO
ONCE THEY LEAVE CAN CAN HIM
WHILE. THAT WE REALLY CONTROL
THE CHOICES AND THE DECISIONS
THEY MAKE AS THEY MOVE ON AS
ADULTS AND WHAT IS AVAILABLE
OKAY. BECAUSE THEY TRIED
SOMETHING. THEY FOUND WHAT. IT
AND THEY FOUND SOMETHING BETTER
OR AN OPPORTUNITY PRESENTED
ITSELF THAT CAUSED THEM TO
CHANGE THEIR TRAINING PEACE SO
WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO TAKE
FACTORS THAT ARE WHAT ONE
SYSTEM USES. BECAUSE IS WHAT
THEY DO HOW THEY'RE ALIGNED.
AND APPLY IT TO A PROGRAM WHERE
WE STRUGGLE NOW WE'RE ALL IN
THE PROCESS NOW OF CREATING OUR
FOLLOW UP DATA FROM THE TWENTY
NINETEEN. HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES
THAT WILL BE TURNED IN AS PART
OF OUR C. TAKE NUMBERS IN MARCH.
THE ATTRITION NUMBER OF
STUDENTS THAT FIND IT TO
CONTACT IN THE SICK MONTH
PERIOD. IS SIGNIFICANT- WHERE
THEY'RE GOING TO BE IN THREE
YEARS IN TWO MORE YEARS IF THEY
FINISH IN TWO YEARS. AND AREN'T
ON THE THREE OR FOUR YEAR PLAN-
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF
CONCERNS ABOUT WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN AND THERE'S A LITTLE BIT
OF A KICK THE CAN DOWN THE ROAD
ATTITUDE OF WELL. I'LL DO THIS
I'LL GET MY PROGRAM STARTED AND
THEN WE'LL FIGURE OUT HOW WE'RE
DOING THAT A LITTLE BIT LATER.
AND THAT'S A CONCERN. I THINK
YOUR POINT IS THAT. THE PROGRAM
IS THIS FOR STUDENTS NOT
STUDENTS DON'T EXIST FOR THE
PROGRAM. SO THANK YOU- IS THERE
ANYTHING ELSE YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE. I DO WANT TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT MR GALLAGHER'S
QUESTION ABOUT. THE FUNDING
OKAY IT IS GOING TO LIVE IN A
LARGE EVEN THOUGH HE'S NOT
HERE- I SU STATUS WATCHING IT
IS OFF THE GREAT GUARANTEE SO.
SO I WON IT JUST CALL ATTENTION
TO THE FACT THAT- IN THE
PREVIOUS ROUNDS OF FUNDING WE
HAD A INITIAL CONVERSATION.
BEFORE THE FIRST ROUND OF
FUNDING WENT OUT A GROUP OF
FOLKS. STAKEHOLDERS FROM THE
STATE WERE CALLED IN TO MEET
WITH. CITY STAFF AND APARTMENT
FINANCE STAFF TO TALK ABOUT.
THIS SMALL MEDIUM LARGE PEOPLE
THAT- DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT
ONKELOS BUT TO. AND WE ALL
PROTEST IT AT THE TIME THAT ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY WAS TOO
SMALL. THE MEDIUM WAS TOO SMALL
AND THE BIG INCLUDED TOO MANY
PEOPLE. AND THERE WERE PERSON
TEN THAT SMALL WORLD AND THEY
REALLY WANTED TO CHECK THE
RURAL AND WE TRIED. IN THOSE.
OF MISS WAS REMOTE. AND LIMITED
AND THEN THAT'S GREAT. MY
DISTRICTS THOSE SEVENTEEN
DISTRICTS THAT PARTICIPATE IN
MY CONSORTIUM APPLICATION. ARE
IN THAT APPLICATION BECAUSE-
THEIR SEVEN. E. EIGHT PUTS THEM
AT FIVE HUNDRED AND. FIFTY TO
EIGHT. AS ON THEIR OWN YET LAST
YEAR WHEN THAT SMALL A SMALL BE
SMALL STE C. PIECE WAS DONE.
THERE WAS NO DIS AGGREGATING OF
WHO WAS IN. THE LARGE GROUP
THAT KIND OF GOT THE LEFTOVERS
IF YOU WILL. SO MY DISTRICTS
TOOK AN EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR HIT. IN OUR CONSOLIDATED
APPLICATION BECAUSE WE WERE
TREATED AS THOUGH ARE TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND COMBINED ADA WAS.
FRESNO UNIFIED OR LOS ANGELES
AND SO ONE OF THE SUGGESTIONS
THAT WE MADE TO CD E. THAT THEY
IN TURN MADE TO THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. THAT THEY HAVE TO
THREE WAS. IF YOU'RE GOING TO
DO SOMETHING WHERE YOU'RE GOIN
CREATE ARBITRARY. CHANGES TO
THE FUNDING. WHEN I WAS A I HAD
A TIME. IN AT LEAST A LOOK AT
WHO ARE. OF THOSE GROUPS AND
YOU HAD A CONSORT THE- I. DON'T
HAVE THE STAFF. NOW TO DO THAT
WHEN APPLE. THEN THOSE
DISTRICTS AND PLACE THEM IN THE
BUCK THEY WOULD BELONGED IN AS
AN INDIVIDUAL APPLICANT. WITH
THEIR MATCH FUND THEM THEN
CONSOLIDATED AND SEND IT BACK
TO US TO HELP THEM DO THEIR
REPORTS BUT DON'T PENALIZE THEM
FOR JOINING US- WHEN IT GETS
FOR THEM IT'S AN EITHER OR IF
WE IF WE WEREN'T HELPING HIM IF
I DIDN'T HAVE STAFF SITTING
HOLDING THEIR HAND. TELLING
THEM HOW TO DO EVERYTHING AND
GIVING IT TO US TO CONSOLIDATE
IT WOULDN'T BE THERE SO I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
REALLY- WHEN THEY LOOK AT THE
DATA. YOU CAN'T TELL WHEN IT
SAYS FRESNO COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT SCHOOLS
ALLOCATION THAT THAT SEVENTEEN
DISTRICTS ON THE ALLOCATION SO
THIS ONE EXTRA WERE REALLY
LOOKING. IN SAYS NOT MAKING A-
BASED ON A NUMBER ASSIGNED
THANKS. TO GET PLAN AND I JUST
OUT OF THE THAT THAT'S- THEY'RE
GREAT AMPLE OF FOR PRESS. ARE
OUT WE CAN TO THE BIZARRE TO
REGIONAL COLLAB. BECAUSE YOU
GET BACK TO NOT PLAY. THANK YOU
TO THE TOWN WHERE WITH THAT
WERE GONNA GO TO COM. YOU COME
TO MY COULD IN. STATE YOUR
AFFILIATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION
AND ALL ONE MINUTE ONLY. ONLY
WE WANT TO HEAR YOU BUT BE
EFFICIENT PLACE. I WONDERED.
WELL I'M CALLING ON WOULD. TRY
AGAIN TEST TEST THERE WE GO. I
JUST WANTED TO THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL FOR THIS
MEETING FRED JONES ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
EDUCATION ASSOCIATION ALSO
FOUND A MEMBER OF THE GET REAL
COALITION- VERY- STRONG
INSIGHTS INTO SOME OF THE
SHORTCOMINGS WITH STRONG WORK
FORCE. APPROACH I WILL REMIND
POLICY MAKERS THAT THERE ARE
SOME HISTORICAL STRUCTURAL
CONCERNS. WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION VIEWS OF THE CITY.
AND SOME FOLKS WHO ARE CLOSELY
INVOLVED WITH PASSING BUDGETS
SURE THOSE CONCERNED SO WE
WOULD LOVE TO WORK WITH YOU IN
ANY EFFORT. POSSIBLY TO REALIGN
SOME OF THESE FUNDS AND FOCUS
THEM MORE AT THE K. TWELVE IN
THE DEPARTMENT LEVEL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MATT PATTON
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION CHIRLA
DONALD AND THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE CONTINUED FOCUS ON
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION AND
THE STUDENTS THAT IT SERVES.
LOOKING AT THE WAY THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO ALLOCATE THESE
FUNDS. EFFICIENTLY AND
ACCURATELY IS WHAT WE NEED TO
DO THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
PUTTING ON THE HEARING MY NAME
IS ALLEY GARNER WITH PROJECT
LEAD THE WAY. I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE THINGS THAT
WERE SAID TODAY THAT I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE GOT ECHOED
I SPOKE WITH ADMINISTRATORS UP
AND DOWN THE STATE ABOUT THIS
PROGRAM. I YUBA CITY LONG BEACH
UNIFIED AND HOW UNIFIED SO HIT
KIND OF ALL OVER THE STATE. AND
A COUPLE THINGS THAT WE NOTICED
WHERE THAT THE ALLOCATIONS FOR
THE STRONG WORK FORCE WERE
DIRECTLY ALLOCATED TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND YET THE
SCHOOLS HAD TO COMPETE FOR
THEIR FUNDS. I THINK THAT THE
KEY TAKE AWAY FOR SCHOOLS
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE THE
DOLLARS ARE SUPPOSED TO GO
DIRECTLY TO THE STUDENTS AND
YET. THE SCHOOLS HAVE TO
COMPETE WHILE COLLEGES
IMMEDIATELY GET THOSE DOLLARS
ADDITIONALLY A TWO TO ONE MATCH
WHERE THERE'S NO MATCH COMING
FROM ANY COMMUNITY COLLEGES IS
A HUGE DISINCENTIVE FOR THE-
FOR THE SCHOOLS TO BE GETTING
THOSE DOLLARS. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AT HIGHS PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION. AS
YOU KNOW. LAST YEAR WE STRONGLY
SUPPORTED EFFORTS. TIME WITH
YOUR LEGISLATION AND OTHERS TO
CONTINUE A C. TAIG FUNDING. AND
TO CONTINUE THE EXISTING
PROGRAMS AS THEY WERE
PREVIOUSLY. WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THE SHIFT HAS OCCURRED AND-
PEOPLE ARE ADJUSTING THAT BUT I
DO WANT TO LINE MY COMMENTS.
WITH FRESNO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. EVERYTHING THEY SAID
MATTERED EXACTLY WHAT OUR
PROGRAM EXPERTS HAVE BEEN
TELLING US- BUT WE ALSO HAD A
CONSORTIUM OF FINDING- THROUGH-
THE COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
WHICH WAS THREE MILLION
DOLLARS. TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
TO THE DISTRICTS. AND THAT
COVERED SEVEN CO EASE- AND SO
THAT FUNDING WAS WHAT WAS BEING
USED TO. SUPPORT THOSE
DISTRICTS. SOME OF THE THINGS
WE HAVE DONE WAS TO HELP. SOME
OF THE C. T. E. PROGRAMMING- BY
A CREDENTIALING TEACHERS AND
PROVIDING SUPPORT THERE- AND
OTHER SERVICES SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU. CD
AND THE ADMINISTRATION OF A
FORWARD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. GOOD APP. OUT DON'T
YOU FOR CONTINUING TO KEEP CITY
IN THE LIMELIGHT- I'M ALYSSA
LYNCH FROM METROPOLITAN
EDUCATION DISTRICT REPRESENTING
SIX DISTRICTS IN THE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY. I'M HERE TO
CONTINUE TO KEEP CENTERS- AT
THE FOUR FRIENDS- CENTERS HAVE
BEEN. I WANT TO SAY SOMETIMES
LEFT OUT OR FORGOTTEN BUT YET
I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE. OF THE
MOVEMENT OF C. T. E. AND C.
TAKE FUNDS. AND WE'RE VERY
FORTUNATE ARDS SIX DISTRICTS
DID PROVIDE US ONE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS LAST YEAR. AND
NOW WE WILL BE RECEIVING ONE
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
OUR DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION
SERVICES LAST YEAR'S SERVED ON
THE- THE RUBRIC COMMITTEE FOR
DEVELOPING THE RUBRIC FOR THE
STRONG WORK FORCE. WE HAVE BEEN
AROUND FOR A HUNDRED YEARS WE
HAVE HIGH QUALITY C. T. A VERY
STRONG REPUTATION FOR
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO. AND WE
DID NOT QUALIFY FOR THE STRONG
WORK FORCE GRANT. WE MISSED IT
BY TWO POINTS. THERE HAVE BEEN
TWENTY SEVEN CENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND NOW THERE ARE
ONLY FOURTEEN. MY BIGGEST FEAR
IS THAT WE TO WILL DISAPPEAR.
WE ARE DEPENDENT ON SEATED
FUNDS AND STRONG WORK FORCE
FUNDS SO I'M HOPING THIS
COMMITTEE CAN CONTINUE TO LOOK
AT ALL CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL MY NAME IS
NICOLE NEWMAN- I'M THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE WHEELING
UNION HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT I
WANT TO ALSO THINK- ASSEMBLYMAN
ON JAMES GALLAGHER OR HIS
ADVOCACY FOR- THIS KAMAL
SCHOOLS IN HIS DISTRICT- MY
SCHOOL HAS EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY
FIVE STUDENTS AND SENATE SEAT
TAKE ORIGINATED IN WE LIVE
WE'VE GONE FROM ONE PATHWAY TO
EIGHT. THE ISSUES FOR SMALL
DISTRICTS IS THAT THERE IS NO
CONSISTENCY OR CLEAR EXCELLENT
EXPLANATION OF HOW WE ARE
FUNDED. LONG TERM PLANNING IS
IMPOSSIBLE IN THE LAST ROUND
AS- ASSEMBLYMAN GALLAGHER SAID
WHEATLAND LOST TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS-
FROM WHAT WAS PUBLICIZED THAT
WAS GOING TO BE. GONNA BE
APPROVED IN THE JANUARY STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION MEETING.
CATEGORIZING THESE SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND MOSTLY RURAL
DISTRICTS AS LARGE WILL BE THE
DEMISE OF ALL THE GREAT WORK.
BETTER STAFF IS DONE THIS
FUNDING ALLOWS US TO CONTINUE
WHAT WE'RE DOING. AND CONTINUE
TO DO WHAT'S BEST FOR KIDS TO
PREPARE THEM FOR LIFE LONG.
THEIR LIFELONG ENDEAVOR WE
SIMPLY CANNOT COMPETE IN THE
SAME. JUST IN THE SAME CATEGORY
AS LA UNIFIED IN BAKERSFIELD.
IT'S INTERESTING THOUGH THAT WE
LEARNED WE APPLIED FOR THE CT
FACILITY PROGRAM- WE WERE
FUNDED FOR THREE MILLION
DOLLARS AND WE WERE CONSIDERED
RURAL BUT WEREN'T NO I GUESS
NOT CONSIDERED SMALL WHEN IT
COMES TO SEE TECH. I JUST WANT
TO JUST SAVE JUST BOBBLE
APPOINTS REAL QUICK WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO BE
CONSISTENT. EQUITY FOR ALL
COMMUNICATION AND- LISTEN TO
THE SMALL DISTRICTS TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND IS A LOT
DIFFERENT THAN. NINE HUNDRED
THANK YOU THANK YOU. CHAIRMAN
O'DONNELL I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING THIS COMMITTEE TO
HEAR FROM ALL THE DIFFERENT
FOLKS YOU HEARD FROM TODAY MY
NAME IS MARIE CALDWELL I AM THE
SUPERINTENDENT A SCOTT VALLEY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
SISKIYOU COUNTY WE HAVEN'T BEEN
ROLLED OUT OF SIX HUNDRED
EIGHTY NINE. AND TYPICALLY OUR
SCHOOLS AND SISKIYOU COUNTY ARE
ALL UNDER TWELVE HUNDRED FOR
VERY SMALL- I WANT TO GIVE A
SHOUT OUT- TO THE C. D. E. THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE DOING A
BETTER JOB OF COMMUNICATION AND
CLARITY ON THE FUNDING CYCLES-
AND ALSO I WANT TO SHARE THAT
WE HAD A REALLY WILDLY
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCE WAS
STRONG. WORK FORCE WERE IN THE
NORTH FAR NORTH REGION WE WERE
VERY WELL ORDER IT. THEM AND
YOU ARE CHECK OUT TO LAST SIX
FOUR THOUSAND AND ARE STRONG
WORK FORCE ALLOCATION WAS A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR
THOUSAND. NO WHERE CONSERVATIVE
DISTRICT WE DO NOT SPEND OUR
GRANT DOLLARS ON SALARY WE
FOCUS OUR GENERAL FUND DOLLARS
ON SALARY THAT ALSO MEANS THAT
THE TO AN MATRAVERS DETAIL
ANSWER WORK IS VERY CHANNEL.
FOR OUR- SCHOOL TRICKS KIND
SCALE IS. HORRIBLE YOU CAN'T DO
IT WITH A TUTOR ONE SO IF I CAN
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO.
STRONGLY ON THAT ONE. MATCH IS
A HE- SYSTEM HE IN FUNDING. AND
JUST SUPPORTING OUR SMALL
MAKING. IT AFTERNOON GOAL ON
BEHALF OF THE CAL CAN COLLEGE
ASSOC FROCK EDUCATION COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND GRADE TWELVE IS A
HAVE ALWAYS HAD IMPORTANT
RELATIONSHIPS BUT WITH A STRONG
WORK FORCE PARTNERSHIP THIS IS
BECOME MORE CRITICAL THAN EVER
SO THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING. THEY GIVE GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M JOE HENDRIX
DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT SUTTER
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS OFFICE WE SERVE TWELVE
DISTRICTS TOTALING ABOUT TWENTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS AND PARTNER
WITH ELLIE A IN NEARBY COUNTIES
TO PROVIDE ROBUST CAREER
EDUCATION OPTIONS FOR STUDENTS
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES I
THINK TODAY'S PRISONERS OF
PROVIDED A COMPELLING CASE THAT
CHANGES NEEDED. I WOULD LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT DRASTIC SHIFT IN
FUNDING HEARD OUR PROGRAMS
STUDENTS TEACHERS FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES THE SHIPS MAKE IT
DIFFICULT TO SUSTAIN EFFECTIVE
PROGRAMS THAT ALLOW STUDENTS TO
COMPLETE CAREER PATHWAYS AND
BECOME JOB ELIGIBLE. ALSO IF WE
WANT OUR STUDENTS TO BE PATHWAY
COMPLETE ORDERS AND PREPARED
FOR SUCCESS AFTER HIGH SCHOOL
WE NEED TO INVEST MORE INVEST
WISELY AND INVEST EQUITABLY.
KEEPING IN MIND THAT SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS DO NOT ENJOY
THE SAME ECONOMIES OF SCALE
THAT ARE LARGER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS DO. FINALLY I WANT TO
THANK THIS COMMITTEE I WANT TO
THANK THE PRESENTERS THAT THAT
HAD A LOT OF WONDERFUL
INFORMATION THANK ASSEMBLYMAN
GALLAGHER WHO WHO'S A
SPOKESPERSON FOR ARTS MALLS AS
WELL. THANK YOU. HELLO I'M
GEORGE READ SOME WITH THE
CALIFORNIA AUTOMOTIVE TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION- THEIR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR. AND I'M GONNA TALK
ABOUT SOMETHING OTHER THAN
FUNDING IF THAT'S ALRIGHT- I
BELIEVE CITY NEEDS TO BE A
GRADUATION REQUIREMENT. I
BELIEVE THAT THE CORE THE
SCHOOL COUNSELORS NEED MORE
TRAINING UP ON CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION. AND THE INSTRUCTORS
ARE COMING FROM INDUSTRY NEED
TO HAVE THEIR- YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE PLACED ON THE SALARY
SCHEDULE THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL
TERRY CAMERINO SUPERINTENDENT
OF NORTH ORANGE COUNTY ROP AN
AXE OUR REGION SEVENTEEN CITY
COUNCIL PRESIDENT ONLY THANK
YOU FOR KEEPING C. T. IN THE
FOREFRONT IT'S GOOD FOR ALL
STUDENTS AND I WANT TO THANK
THE PRESENTERS TO BECAUSE I
THINK WHAT THEY SAID. IS BEST
FOR STUDENTS OF THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME'S PATTY ROMO
AND I SERVE INTO ROLES I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION FOR
CAPISTRANO UNIFIED AND I ALSO
SERVE IN THE ROLE OF THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF THERE ARE- P.
WITH LAGUNA BEACH UNIFIED SO MY
TO DISTRICTS SERVE ABOUT FIFTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS IN SOUTH
ORANGE COUNTY- OF THE SIXTEEN
THOUSAND HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
TWELVE THOUSAND OF THEM ARE
ENROLLED IN- CAREER PATHWAYS.
SO ABOUT 65% AND WE HAVE FIVE
THOUSAND STUDENTS TAKING MIDDLE
SCHOOL CLASSES IN CT THE CZ
INTEGRATE FUNDS SAVED US
BECAUSE OUR BUDGET WAS CUT
ABOUT 66% YEARS AGO MY LARGE
DISTRICT IS ONE OF THOSE EL CFF
LOSERS AND SO THEY'RE RECEIVING
PER PUPILS- FUNDING OF ABOUT
NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
STUDENT. AND EVERY NEW MANDATE
EVERY NEW- COST INCREASE PUTS
THEM IN A TERRIBLE POSITION OF-
A ROCK AND A HARD PLACE AND SO
C. T. E. SOMETIMES AS MUCH AS
THEY SUPPORT CITY AS MUCH AS
CITY HAS REFORMED EDUCATION IN
SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY DONE SOME
FANTASTIC THINGS WHEN THEY'RE
PUT IN THAT POSITION. WE'RE
REALLY TRULY RELYING ON THIS
STATE GRANT FUNDING TO KEEP US
GOING SO I THINK YOU I
APPRECIATE EVERY DAHLE AND-
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
CONTINUING TO LOOK AT THIS
FUNDING. MERRY WHY DIDN'T
COUNTY OUR OWN AND I WANT TO.
THE LIKE MY SISTER IN FRESNO
COUNTY HAS ALSO SAID ABOUT- THE
LITTLE GUYS TO BECAUSE THAT'S
WHO I REPRESENT TO IS THE SMALL
SCHOOL RULES SCHOOLS. WHO
CANNOT BE STRETCHED ANY THINNER
AND IT'S WITH MATCH THE MATCH
THAT THEY USE FOR C. TAKE THEY
HAVE NO MATCH AVAILABLE FOR K.
TWELVE THEN. SO THAT'S WHY WE
DO IT CONSORTIUM FOR K. TWELVE.
AND IN DOING THAT ANOTHER
REASON WE HAVE TO DO THAT FOR
THEM IS THE SMALL SCHOOLS
USUALLY HAVE ONE PERSON DOING.
AG INCENTIVE- CARL PERKINS THE
CT INCENTIVE GRANTS AND THEY'RE
ALSO TEACHING FULL TIME WITH
HARDLY WITH NO PERHAPS. SO THEY
CAN'T DO ANOTHER GRANT SO
THAT'S WHERE WE HAVE STEPPED IN
AND TRIED HER BEST TO HELP OUT
BUT THEN AGAIN WE'RE SPREADING.
ENOUGH DOLLARS ALONG WITH. AND
IT'S JUST NOT EFFECTIVE SO WE
DO APPRECIATE WHAT WE HAD IT'S
KEPT THEM AFLOAT BUT WE WOULD
APPRECIATE CSUS SUSTAINABILITY
THANK YOU. GREAT THANK YOU- BUT
I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL THE
PANELISTS TODAY I'D LIKE TO
THINK THE SUPERINTENDENT FOR
SURE. ALSO THE LA- AND THE- THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE FOR BEING
HERE TODAY A VERY GOOD JOB
THANK YOU- A SIGNIFICANT AND
SUSTAINED FUNDING STREAM. TO
ESTABLISH AND SUPPORT HIGH
QUALITY CTA PROGRAMS AS
CRITICAL WE KNOW THAT'S WE'VE
HEARD ABOUTSOME OF THE FUNDING
ISSUES. WE ALSO HEARD- SOME OF
THE ISSUES SURROUNDING
LOGISTICS OF APPLYING AND THEN
ALSO ONCE YOU GET THE GROUND.
AND THEN ALSO. HOW THE DATA'S
USE RELATIVE TO. THE OUTCOMES
OF THE GRANT SO THOSE ARE ALL
IMPORTANT. AND I THINK ONE OF
THE BIG OVER ARCHING ISSUES I
SEE HERE IS THAT WE'VE GOT TO.
TWO STREAMS OF FUNDING THAT.
FOR THE MOST PART SEEM TO DO.
THE SAME THING. AND THEN
THERE'S SOME COLLABORATION
ISSUES WITH SOME COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN. G. WHO'S IN CHARGE
AND REALLY WHO SHOULD BE IN
CHARGE IS STUDENT OUTCOMES SO
MAYBE THAT'S NOT ALWAYS
HAPPENING. SO I WANT TO- I WANT
TO THANK ALL THOSE WHO
PARTICIPATED IN AND I THINK
WHAT WE'VE LEARNED TODAY IS
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE AN
ONGOING. CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW
THIS PROGRAM IS FUNDED FOR
SURE. I'D LIKE TO SEE THERE'D
BE IN A MORE OLLARS FOR C. T.
BUT ALSO HOW IT'S OPERATED
LOGISTICS ASSOCIATED- WITH THIS
PROGRAM NEED FOR THAT IT.
SHOULD AS WELL AND AGAIN I WANT
TO THANK ALL THE PRESENTERS AND
ALL THOSE WHO SAT OUT THERE AND
LISTEN DILIGENTLY. AND PURCHASE
IT IT PAID IN OUR CONVERSATION
TODAY THANK YOU. FOR THAT THIS
HEARING IS ADJOURNED.